ok ich dachte mir wir spielen noch mal eine runde
habe euch ja versprochen als das game noch vom release war dass ich öfter stream werde ich mache das jetzt einfach auch
ich muss ja auch ein bisschen was aus meinen 70 80 oder wie viel hat es gekostet wie viel kostet die battle for gold edition
ein bisschen was rauskriegen von meiner kohle bf 2020 gold edition
key for steam ja das
140 was ist denn mit euch los
was der kram gerade
Ja ja spiel holen einfach was mein gott sagt mir einfach was es kostet
90 euro das ist ein bisschen bisschen was für meine 90 euro musste auch rauskriegen
Da spielen wir einfach so ein paar runden
und ich werde sicherlich kein großer fan des games mehr so viel kann ich schon gleich sagen weil die letzten tage nicht dabei waren
auch wenn es echt gar nicht schlecht lief
Ne muss man ja mal sagen es waren wirklich paar richtig coole runden dabei
Der ostsee junge ohne werte ist auch schon 19 monate richtig pockers und du hast jetzt die gold keks am start
Exquisite den gold keks den übrigens wir vielleicht an der stelle auch mal sagen den gold keks dienst ohne den wettlust gar nicht gäbe
Weil er hat den designer designerin in dem fall gesucht für die kekse
exquisite
next level shit
also capenpocker ausfallswerk
du mitmachen willst oder hier auch moritz falls du mitmachen willst aber ich bin ich bezweifel ich
bezweifelt bis sie lauter müssen wir glaube ich machen als games zu leise ist richter stream
marathon im urlaub ja ich bin gespannt also was wir heute auf jeden fall heute werden wir
definitiv nicht ganz so lang also wie wir spielen wahrscheinlich wieder bis 23 uhr aber wir werden
nicht die ganze zeit nur das game spielen wir werden uns auch mal ein paar sachen noch auf
youtube angucken zum beispiel ein paar comments lesen unter meinem video da sind wir ein paar
absolut wurde genau da sind wir ein paar absolut haarsträubende dinger dabei wo ich mir auch genau
gab schon wieder gibt jeden tag jeden tag gibt es keinen patch der was fix wir kommen super wie
wir können so ein paar sachen an dann noch ein paar andere videos wo sie leute darüber aufnehmen müssen
wir gucken uns das video vom lost an habe ich nämlich vorhin gesehen dass der was hoch
geladen hat wo er sich ein bisschen drüber ausgekotzt hat das problem jetzt jetzt fangen
sie alle an ich muss erst mal wieder ein raushauen jetzt fangen sie alle an dann habe ich ein video
gesehen von ihm hier dass das kenne ich das hatte ich schon mal angefangen zu schauen und ich habe
am anfang raus gehört er findet das video eigentlich relativ gut aber warum ich das noch mal weiter
gucken will wobei ich weiß ja ob die 33 vielleicht überspringen ein bisschen anscheinend irgendwie
bezug auf mein video genommen zumindest hat mir das einer geschrieben ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt bin
ich mal gespannt was er erzählt und dann gucken wir noch mal die leute hier ist nein das gucken wir
nicht noch mal ja ihr wisst was ich meine aber jetzt spielen wir erstmal schnell eine runde ich
trage den keppen vorgas ein nicht wundern dass es im hauptmenü ruckelt das ist normal sobald wir
in game sind ruckels nicht mehr und ich muss mal kurz meine anti meine nacken entspannungs
anti kopfweh übung machen schon spät schon alt ab einem gewissen alter muss man das machen und
jetzt geht's alles klar ob die ich die karte in battlefield 3 fürs queen machen kann du kannst
im battlefield 3 relativ vielen der konflikt daten stellen mussten mal gucken aus dem kopf weiß ich
das weiß ich das nicht richtig richtig viel spät wie gesagt ich kann ich kann mir das empfehlen
falls du falls du falls du kopf falls du kopf spotschmerzen hast und hier so ihren nacken und
sonstwas wenn er einfach die hände so mal verhängt den kopfschmerzen ist das ist wichtig wenn du so
die hände so mal verhängt und nacken und sonstwas wenn er einfach die hände so mal verhängt und des jetzt
der kopfschmerzen an den kopfschmerzen und hier so einen nacken und sonstwas wenn er einfach die hände so mal
verschränkst, hinter den Kopf nimmst und dann quasi mit der
Rückseite vom Kopf so in die Hände
drückst und mit den Händen dagegen.
Weiß nicht, wie man diese Übung nennt, aber
das hilft bei mir immer.
Puma, Nacken tut weh, Kopf.
Oh, ey, ja, was soll ich denn sagen?
So, wen haben wir denn sonst noch?
Will sonst noch jemand, Leute?
Will sonst noch jemand?
Sehe ich da gerade, dass der Moritz
auch am Start ist?
Dann laden wir den auch ein.
Falls der mitmachen will.
Stretching mit Max, so sieht's aus.
Nice, auf geht's.
GG Eats.
Äh, Con... Nein, nein, nein. Breakthrough, Breakthrough.
Lustigerweise
ist Conquest eigentlich der bessere Modus,
aber durch dieses ewig lange
Rennen ist Breakthrough dann
zumindest kurzweiliger.
Ist Day 3 Patch ein
G-Bait?
He lacks critical information.
Ja, das ist ein G-Bait.
Das ist ein G-Bait.
Weil
he doesn't know.
Ich hab den ersten Tag
das gleiche geschrieben, den zweiten Tag
das gleiche geschrieben, jetzt schreibe ich den dritten Tag halt auch einfach
das gleiche.
Ich schreibe jetzt jeden Tag, wo wir Battlefield spielen,
Day 4 Patch hat alles gefixt,
Day 5 Patch hat alles gefixt.
Mal gucken, vielleicht kommt ja der Tag,
wo der Patch
dann wirklich
was fixt.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Stellt euch mal vor, wir schreiben das jetzt
240 Tage,
und am 241.
Tag kommt dann der Patch, der alles
fixt. Wobei, nächste Woche
kommt ja wirklich ein Patch. Aber ob
der jetzt so viel behebt, na, warten wir
das mal ab, okay. Machen wir kurz die Musik aus.
Sagt mir mal jetzt, ob es laut genug ist.
Es dürfte nicht ruckeln.
Es dürfte nicht ruckeln, es müsste
laut genug sein, und
ähm,
achso, Moment, ah, hat mein Battlefield die Auflösung wieder geändert.
Zeck.
Nein, hä? Jetzt stimmt alles.
Na gut. Booster.
Und Booster.
Alles klar. Oh Gott.
Das ist Discarded. Leute,
Discarded Breakthrough, ich sag's euch.
Ich muss jetzt, ich muss jetzt, das ist jetzt, das ist mein Trick.
Ich hab festgestellt, das funktioniert.
Umso beruhigter ich spreche, umso weniger
rege ich mich nicht auf in dem Spiel. Also ich muss
hyper, hyper relaxed.
Ah, yes.
Ja, erstmal eine Runde spotten.
Spot, spotten.
Oh, oh, oh. Wow!
Alter, bitte mehr Beschleunigung
aus dem Heli raus, wenn's geht.
Okay, wir switchen mal.
Sag mal!
Was zum Teufel ist mit dem?
Ich hab den Wingsuit gezündet.
Was ist mit dem Game los wieder?
Nochmal.
Das Game.
Nice. Next, please.
Wir spielen heute mal, ich versuch heute mal,
MP9 zu spielen. Es kann aber sein,
dass wir das nicht lange durchhalten und
PPGA29 anschauen müssen. Sag mal,
kann das sein, dass
wir hier im Stream PPGA29
erfunden haben? Ich kann mich nicht
dran erinnern, dass das irgendjemand gesagt hatte,
bevor ich hier im Stream mit angefangen hab.
Und ich glaube, ich hab im Stream damit angefangen,
weil das irgendjemand von euch gesagt hat.
Weil ich irgendwie Witze gemacht hab, PP29
und die Leute haben dann gesagt, mehr PPGA29.
Und jetzt sagt es,
jetzt sagen es alle.
Jetzt sagen sie das alle hier.
Insgesättet, würde ich sagen.
Nein, ich brauch die Granate.
Der Lost sagt,
ich weiß, der Lost sagt jetzt auch.
Ich glaub, das hat sich...
Hallo? Ich kann mich nicht mehr selbst heilen
mit dem Shortcut. Ah, weil ich
voll bin. Okay, das wird's natürlich erklären.
Och nö.
Dachte jetzt, die kommt hier rumgestellst
und kriegt dann aus und aus.
Lebt da noch was?
Was auch immer.
Makrob in die Richtung geschossen.
Oh, alles klar.
DM7.
GG Eats. Gute Sniper.
Two-Hit.
Sieht bei mir das nur so rucklig ausgefühlt.
30 bis 45. Meinst du jetzt im Stream
oder meinst du jetzt
bei dir im Spiel selbst?
Weil im Stream sieht's bei mir
eigentlich relativ
okay aus.
Ich seh's grad in der Vorschau, also...
Sag mal, ist okay?
Okay, die Vorschau auf Amt 2.
Der Stream? Wirklich?
Moment, das muss ich mal kurz jetzt...
Kann sein, dass ich sterbe. Ich muss mal kurz in, äh,
auf dem Handy gucken, ob das flüssig ist.
Weil mein zweiter Rechner ist da nicht die...
Ähm, der, äh, im zweiten Rechner
ist das nicht aussagekräftig.
Wenn ich da gucke, live.
Okay, Sekunde.
Muss ich das mal einschalten.
Es kann sein, dass das aus irgendwelchen Gründen rumbackt.
Ja, gucken wir mal.
Wollen wir kurz ein bisschen im Kreis rennen. Ich muss auf dem Handy gucken.
Achtung, ich bin übrigens mitten im Gegnergebiet, was eigentlich witzig ist.
So, ich muss jetzt auf dem Handy gucken,
ob es flüssig ist.
Falls sich das irgendwann mal ein, ein bekommt.
Nö.
Das sieht eigentlich
ziemlich gut aus.
Das sieht eigentlich okay aus.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Sag mal, ich lieg hier seit 3 Stunden im Gegnerspawn.
Keinen interessiert's.
Wie kann das sein?
Warum spottet mich mal
wenigstens jemand?
Wäre es vielleicht möglich, dass hier niemand ist?
Mhm, mhm, mhm.
Bling.
Ich muss sagen, den Headshot, den Headshot-
Boah.
Das ist schwer, schwer so einen Satz zu bilden.
Der Headshot-Sound.
Der ist tatsächlich relativ gut.
Also sollte der Stream-Bahn noch irgendjemand ruckeln.
Jetzt kommen sie, jetzt kommen sie.
Sollte der Stream-Bahn noch irgendjemand ruckeln,
dann sagt mir Bescheid, dann mache ich Game Capture.
Wie er einfach rübergeslidet ist.
Ich wollte hier überhaupt nicht ruf.
Guck mal, hier ist alles voll.
Ich kann nicht aimen.
ADS geht nicht.
Ich kann nicht zoomen.
Alter.
Aiming Downside war einfach
grad disabled.
Es ging einfach nicht mehr.
Es war einfach aus.
Ne, passt soweit, okay.
Lass mich mal in meiner Vorschau kurz checken.
Ist ein Patch gekommen?
Es ist kein Patch gekommen, der was
behebt. Ne.
Ah, Mist. Ach, guck mal, wir kriegen A1.
Oh, nice. Die sind relativ schwer,
diese ersten beiden Bases,
find ich.
Dementsprechend haben wir vielleicht Glück.
Und können da jetzt mit rein.
Ja, sehr gut. Sehr schön.
Die sind so flach, seht ihr das?
Das ist einfach ne Ebene,
wo sie sich gedacht haben, naja.
Machen wir einfach mal.
Machen wir mal so zwei Container drauf.
Das reicht schon.
Zwei Container und das reicht.
Das muss ausreichen.
Wer will schon
mehr als zwei Container?
Was? Weird Game? Layout?
Was?
Also, das ist vieles weird champ an dem Game,
aber das Layout?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Habt ihr gesehen, die kann Granaten werfen,
ohne den Arm zu benutzen?
Ich hab übrigens schon längst geswitcht.
Aber das Game hat
es nicht mitbekommen.
Okay.
Yolo.
Jetzt hier, volle Pulle. Gib ihm.
Gib ihm.
Digga, gib ihm.
Sagt man heute so, hab ich mir sagen lassen.
Aber ich dachte, man kann jetzt hier abheben vielleicht.
Haha.
Natürlich.
Natürlich von der Seite.
Aber was sonst, was sonst.
Das ist ja auch so ein Kritikpunkt,
also eigentlich wirklich ein riesen Kritikpunkt an dem Game,
den ich hab durch die vielen Spieler.
Du siehst einen,
dich sehen fünf bis fünfzehn.
Das ist halt heftig.
Überall anders wär man jetzt durchgegangen wie nix.
Hätten einfach noch die zwei, drei
verbleibenden gebasht.
Geht kein Hit. Nice.
Was es geht um MW3?
Hast du mitbekommen,
dass am Donnerstag
die Closed Beta startet?
Soll bis März dauern und ab da
soll es in die Open Beta gehen
und Free-to-Play für die Closed Beta
spielen sich quasi.
Äh, wie MW3.
Es kommt doch jetzt erst MW2
und nächstes Jahr Call of Duty.
Was für ein MW3.
Das alte MW3 oder, oder, oder, oder, hä?
Ach, World War 3.
Ja, das wird doch eh nix.
Also, das Game.
Ich hab das ja Early Access
gedingst damals auf Steam.
Also, das was ich bisher gesehen hab,
hat mich mal überhaupt nicht geschockt.
Mal gar nicht.
Oh, oh.
Ey, dieses Game.
Du bist da und du bist von allen Seiten
weg, Gachibast.
Also, ich hab,
ich hab das mal gespielt,
als das, als das...
Sekunde, ich brauch das richtige E-Mail.
Weiter geht's.
Vielleicht soll ich einfach wieder auf PP29 switchen.
Mit PP29 ist alles einfacher.
Damals hätt's was werden können.
Ich glaub, dass das...
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal,
dass die eineinhalb Jahre da viel was dran gemacht haben.
Ich hab, ähm...
vor...
zwei, drei Monaten so nen Close Test
bisschen geguckt auf Twitch.
Und das Game
war im Prinzip noch mehr oder weniger das gleiche
wie zu diesem Close Test.
Nur mit dem Unterschied...
Alter, was ist denn hier los, man?
Äh...
The fuck, Alter?
Wie willst du denn... Okay, wir...
Vielleicht können wir so'n Hovercraft droppen. Können wir so'n Hovercraft
natürlich nicht.
Vielleicht darf ich so was droppen jetzt?
Oh, das ist ja...
Das ist ja so nice, guck mal. Dice hat sich
gedacht... Also hier, das ist wie
Harvest Day, nur in schlecht.
Findet ihr... Guck mal, guck mal.
Das ist ein bisschen wie Harvest Day.
Guckt euch mal die Map an, so, vom Feld her.
Nur in schlecht, weil
in Harvest Day hattest du so Hügel,
also so, so, so, so...
Lass mich in Ruhe, ich will Harvest Day
erklären, Mensch.
Pass mal auf, der wird jetzt PP-Guard.
Hätte auch
funktionieren können. Hätte auch funktionieren können,
aber...
Man kann's ja mal probieren.
Ähm... Ja, Harvest Day
hatte so Trenches, hatte rechts
den Hügel, hatte links den, den,
den Fluss.
Ähm... Hatte dann
einen M-Com mit ein paar unzerstörbaren Teilen
und so. Also da muss man schon sagen,
Harvest Day war halt durchdacht, aber es hat schon was
von Harvest Day.
Die Idee war gut, ne? Aber
das, ja... Da sind ja...
Habt ihr's gesehen? Das
Problem war nicht der Typ, auf den ich zugeflogen
bin. Das Problem war,
dass in der Zwischenzeit, glaub fünf Leute
oder so wieder bei dem gespawnt sind.
So, wir machen jetzt den Flank
des Jahrhunderts.
Vielleicht können wir sogar ein bisschen rüberfliegen, wenn wir...
Aber wir kommen ja nicht so weit.
Weiter kommen wir nicht.
Kann nicht überall hin
gleiten.
Ah, da ist ein Hovercraft. Krieg ich auch ein Hovercraft?
Komm, gib mir ein Hoverc... Ah, ich darf B nicht drücken.
Aber in fünf Sekunden darf ich B drücken.
Ich bleib jetzt einfach liegen.
Und dann...
Wenn...
Okay, warum genau
ist B auf dem Cooldown gewesen und
ist jetzt deaktiviert?
Ach, guck mal!
Da kommt ein Auto.
Vielleicht kann ich den
Flanken von hinten... Oder...
Harz-Disabled-Käck-Waid.
Guck mal!
Nein, nein.
Der freut sich jetzt, Leute.
Was will ich denn hier machen, bitteschön?
Kann mir irgendjemand erklären, wie ich den
Typ in irgendeiner Art und Weise...
Was soll ich... Was willst du tun?
Ja, aber...
Nichts, machst nichts einfach nur.
Ja, nice. Nice. Gatschi-Bars in the bobbins.
Gib's mir von... Ja, nice.
Gut.
Mach, alles klar.
Oh, nice, da geh ich jetzt hoch.
Da geh ich jetzt hoch und lass mich auf den Weg hoch.
Alter, der wird so gebasht, der Dude.
Mann, ich dachte, das ist ein Gegner.
Da liegt doch noch einer, oder?
Ne, der ist down.
Oder ist der Typ ganz oben?
Kann man hier eigentlich auch hoch?
Ne.
Okay, ich geb zu, Leute.
Ich habe nicht, ich habe nicht
die richtige Waffe dafür.
Die Waffe ist etwas
etwas sackig dafür.
Warum gucken die?
Fuck, Mann. Warum gucken die?
Warum wissen die, dass ich da bin?
Die wissen einfach, dass ich am Start bin.
Obwohl ich hinter ihnen auf dem Kran stehe.
Gut, wegen dem
Motion-Sensor wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe runtergeschossen, ihr Hund.
Das sind 50 Milliarden Punkte.
Die wissen doch nicht, dass ich da auf dem Kran bin.
Ah, nice. Die kloppen sich mit dem Auto.
Okay.
Also,
okay, ich würde jetzt gerne
mal Dice anrufen.
Hallo, Dice, Schweden?
Was soll ich machen?
Ich bräuchte einen Coach von Dice, der mir erklärt,
was man sich hierbei gedacht hat.
Der Söderlund ist doch frei.
Den haben sie doch rausgeschmissen nach Battlefield 5.
Vielleicht kann er, vielleicht hat er noch genug Ahnungen davon,
wie das, wie das funktioniert.
Vielleicht soll ich immer auf Fiverr.
Wollen wir mal gucken. Vielleicht sind hier auf Fiverr ein paar Dice-Developer,
die mich coachen können.
Wie man, wie man hier vorgeht
auf diesen Maps, dass man,
dass man hier durchkommt.
Ich brauche Dice-Coaches.
Anders geht's.
Anders geht das nicht.
Ja.
Nice.
Sehr gut.
Das ist einfach Zucker.
Ja.
Ne, es wird nicht,
äh, Royal, es wird nicht dasselbe Theater wie bei Battlefield 4.
Der Unterschied zwischen Battlefield 2 und Battlefield 2.40 und, ähm,
Battlefield 4 ist,
dass du eigentlich von Anfang an erkennen konntest,
dass in Battlefield 4 ein richtig gutes Game steckt.
Zumindest ich.
Ich weiß,
da kann man sich drüber streiten.
Es gibt Leute, die sehen das anders,
aber zumindest ich erkenne das hier nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wovon er schießt.
Mit dem Enterhaken.
Ich habe keinen Enterhaken.
Ich habe den Wingsuit dabei.
Also ich finde, fast für diese Map müsste es ein Mobility-Held geben mit Enterhaken und Wingsuit.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo der ist.
Wo ist der überhaupt?
Von wo werde ich überhaupt beschossen?
Ich weiß nicht.
DLC-Hero.
Okay, vielleicht können wir,
vielleicht können wir noch ein Stückchen fliegen.
Die Leiter ist auch komisch.
Ach ja, ach ja,
da ist er.
Obvious.
Also Chat, das hätte man schon mal predikten können,
dass der da jetzt ist.
Das hätte man wissen müssen.
Ich finde, das ist eigentlich ziemlich offensichtlich gewesen.
Ich habe da nicht hingekommen.
Es war offensichtlich, dass der da steht.
Das war einfach,
zu offensichtlich.
So, okay, uns bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig, als
PP29 zu spielen.
Seht ihr ja gerade, es ist ja nicht...
Was willst du machen?
Du hast nicht die Re... Okay, wir haben verloren.
It's predict.
Sehr cringe.
Sehr cringe. Ja.
Richtig cringe.
Gebe ich dir recht, das ganze Game ist cringe.
Die armen Devs.
Stell dir mal vor, das Game,
woran du die letzten Jahre gearbeitet hast, ist
scheiße zum zweiten Mal.
Also, in der Haut der Devs
möchte ich wirklich nicht stecken.
Weil die kriegen es in der Regel
doppelt beschissen ab.
Die müssen ein Game machen,
worauf sie, also worauf
sie eigentlich wahrscheinlich schon fast erwarten,
dass es nicht gut ankommt.
Und
am Ende, wenn es nicht gut läuft,
werden sie wahrscheinlich auch noch rausgeschmissen,
weil es nicht gut gelaufen ist und jetzt irgendwie
Leute entlassen werden oder sonst was.
Ja.
Also das ist...
Das ist echt dumm.
Also ich glaube, du kannst
als Projektleiter,
Developer, Designer
an diesem Spiel
eigentlich nur verlieren.
Also den, den es als
erstes trifft, ist der
Wikinger-Typ. Ich weiß nicht, wie er heißt.
Da der
DICE-Projektleiter da von diesem Game,
der auch immer in den Videos am Start war,
der, wie gesagt, so straight
aus Vikings aussieht.
Auch vom Bart her und so.
Wenn ich jetzt sage, der eine Schwede,
dann wisst ihr nicht, wen ich meine,
weil das sind alles Schweden.
Und
den trifft es wahrscheinlich als erstes.
Der hat wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit gesagt,
Leute, das Game ist nicht fertig, das Game wird kacke,
das wird schlecht ankommen und die haben gesagt,
nein, nein, das passt schon, wir patchen das alles.
Ja, na, mach mal raus, mach mal raus.
Jetzt aber, jetzt muss es aber raus, ja.
Und er ist der Erste, der seinen Job verliert,
weil das Game nicht gut ist.
Nein, wow, das habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ja, müsste man machen.
Ich habe leider vergessen, wann ich das gesagt habe.
Ich will jetzt nicht, ich will jetzt nicht
das ganze Wort durchgucken.
Oh nein, come on, come on, please.
Erst das und jetzt break away.
Leute, wir haben noch einen Slot frei,
will noch irgendjemand das Elend sich mit an...
Ah, der Serious Max ist doch auch da.
Okay, passt, ist alles voll.
Ich habe mich verguckt.
Gibt es eigentlich wie in der Beta Bots?
Ja, es gibt Bots.
Es gibt Bots sogar theoretisch
in drei verschiedenen Schwierigkeiten.
Doch, die Map ist schlechter als die letzte.
Du wirst es gleich sehen.
Kannst du mal ein Jet nehmen?
Nein, ich fliege keinen Jet.
Ja, also wie gesagt, die Bots gibt es in drei verschiedenen Schwierigkeiten.
Ich glaube Beginner, Intermediate und Advanced.
Advanced.
Und mir ist heute Morgen was aufgefallen,
was mit diesen Bots,
also wegen diesen Bots.
Nämlich,
dass man Attachments für die Waffen,
ich überlege gerade,
dass man Attachments,
für die Waffen,
mit Bots freispielen kann.
Ich habe das heute Morgen ausprobiert.
Ich habe gedacht,
ach Mist, du musst ja noch für die MP9
die Attachments freispielen.
Also, was habe ich gemacht?
Mal versucht, Bots, Bot-Match aufzumachen.
Und habe 120 Kills gemacht, Bots.
Und danach hatte ich fast alles
mit der MP9 freigeschaltet.
Das geht.
Ist die laut, oder?
Oder passt die Lautstärke so?
Ne, passt, passt, glaube ich.
Oh, oh, oh.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich will keine Cringe.
Äh, kein,
ich will den bashen hier,
ich will die bashen, Alter.
Merke, es ist immer der,
den du nicht siehst in diesem Battlefield.
Und es ist ganz schrecklich.
Okay, nice.
Fetzt dich.
Okay, auf.
Da fahren wir jetzt hin
und klatschen mit der 30mm rein.
Alter.
Gib ihm.
Gachi-Bass.
Gachi-Bass, Mann.
Fuck.
Aber richtig reingefahren von hinten.
Aber das Ding ist übrigens
in Hazard Zone
abfuck-OP.
Ich kann es nicht anders sagen.
Also, ich habe ja vorhin
in Hazard Zone gespielt, ein paar Stunden.
Ich muss ja dann morgen noch ein Sponsored-Video
zu machen.
Pains Champ.
Ähm.
Und.
Wenn du dort ein Auto hast,
mit diesem 30mm-Geschütz,
oder noch schlimmer,
du hast zwei Autos mit dem 30mm-Geschütz,
dann bist du unbesiegbar.
Magst du es gekauft?
Confirmed. Ja, ist so.
Das ist nicht nur, also,
das ist insofern confirmed,
ich habe es ja selbst gesagt.
Alter, lass mich doch mal in Ruhe hier.
Ich will doch einfach nur mal da rausgucken,
ohne von irgendeinem Typ gesniped zu werden.
Ey, das ist
richtig cringe, das Game.
Ja.
Ey, please, kriege ich ein Rätsel vielleicht?
Guck mal, da sind so viele Leute.
Revive, request, help.
Ach, nein, das sind Gegner.
Nein, da wird mich jetzt garantiert keiner reviven.
Morgen kommt das Video Battlefield Bestes Game.
Oh, ja.
Also, wenn dieses Video irgendwann mal kommt,
dann wahrscheinlich frühestens in einem Jahr.
Und dann auch nur, wenn sie komplett die Kurve gekriegt haben.
Aber komplett, was ich nicht glaube.
Ich wollte eigentlich hier.
Okay, dann.
In the ass.
Ah.
KGW.
Da sitzt er.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, im Busch.
Nee, im Busch sitzt er nicht.
Im Container sitzt er.
Passt im Busch.
Darfst du in den Placement...
Autsch.
Ach, da.
Darfst du in den Placement deine eigene Meinung sagen?
Ja, darf ich.
Also, ich darf im Prinzip
alles sagen, was ich will.
Aber, sie müssen das Video abnehmen.
Was im Endeffekt heißt,
ja, ich darf alles sagen, was ich will.
Ob ich das Video dann zeigen darf,
ist wieder was anderes.
Hallo, hallo.
Motion Sensor, please.
Oh no, ja.
Ey, das ist so...
Alter, was ist denn da um die Ecke los?
Da ist der Bus stehen geblieben.
Und jetzt sind alle ausgestiegen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das sind 40 Gegner.
Hinter diesem Felsen, jetzt legit, Leute.
Hinter diesem Felsen.
Stehen mehr, als
als ein komplette Runde
Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4, also alle Battlefields bisher
überhaupt Spieler drin hatten.
So ist es.
So sieht's aus.
Und welcher der Felsen ist es überhaupt gewesen?
Wo ist der Felsen, wo sie alle stehen?
Da ist ein Panzer.
The Pants Man.
Schmeißen wir mal hier einen Motion Sensor.
Vielleicht kriegen wir irgendwas.
Okay.
Wir laufen jetzt über das offene Feld.
Oh ne, da sind sie schon.
Uns bleibt nichts anderes übrig, als über das offene Feld zu laufen.
Immer da, wo du nicht hinguckst, ja.
Vielleicht kriege ich noch einen Reds.
Warte mal, sind das überhaupt...
Sind das überhaupt Teammates?
Help, help, help.
Boris.
Gekommnet, mein Freund Boris.
Rett's mich.
Nice.
Ich find's auch geil, wenn so Sachen wie dieser Grappling Hook einfach nicht funktionieren.
Nice, easy win.
Jetzt ging er aber gut durch hier.
Da kannst du nix sagen.
Hast du, hast du richtig...
Was, hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Hast du kein TDM?
Nein, es gibt kein TDM.
Du kannst in Portal TDM spielen, aber es gibt kein All Out Warfare TDM.
Es gibt in dem Spiel eigentlich nichts.
Daran kannst du dich gewöhnen.
Also es gibt...
Ja, es gibt nichts.
Es gibt ein...
Es gibt zwei Spielmodi.
Und sieben Maps.
Das war's.
Also...
Also alles, was nicht zu diesen zwei Spielmodi gehört und in sieben Maps, die gibt es nicht.
Das...
Das ist nicht vorhanden.
Guck mal, der hat nicht PPGA 29 gespielt und schon ist er down.
Oh Mann!
Jetzt hab ich hier den...
Den...
Den Five Head Eleven Head flank gemacht.
Und?
Was ist passiert?
Nix.
Hat nicht funktioniert.
Da schreit noch einer rum.
Hier ist doch noch einer, oder?
Warum schreien die noch rum?
Die sind doch tot.
Wie können die nur rum schreien?
Hyper Clap.
Ouh, da drüben!
Guckt es euch mal an!
Da drüben geht es rund.
Oh, da unten.
Guck mal da.
Was ist denn da unten?
Oh, da drüben.
Da drüben.
Oh, fuck, Mann.
Oh, oh, oh.
No.
Hier ist so viel Deckung.
Ich glaube, ich hätte mich hier unter diesem Hügel vielleicht verstecken können.
Hier, guck hier so.
Hier.
Hier ist Deckung.
Seht ihr das?
Massive Deckung.
Jetzt sagt, da sagt mal einer, das Spiel hat keine Deckung.
Guck mal hier.
Also, da ist schon verdammt viel Deckung da.
Da ist schon, da ist schon.
Kann man nicht sagen, dass da keine Deckung gibt.
Fake News.
Deckung ist vorhanden.
Oh.
Ja, das mit dem Main Weapon nicht in die Hand nehmen können, kommt manchmal vor.
Achtung, Nate.
Ah, ich habe hier gar keine Granate.
Sag mal, wo müssen wir eigentlich hin?
Ich bin vollkommen ratlos, wo es eigentlich lang geht.
Ach, da unten.
Halber Kilometer.
Auf geht's.
Hovercrafts.
Mehr Hovercrafts.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, also, es wird mal Zeit für irgendwie so einen Film.
Predator vs. Hovercraft oder sowas.
Okay, ich gebe zu, das war jetzt doch schon, der Witz war äußerst, wir Champ, aber.
Wenn man zu viel Battlefield 2042 gespielt hat, dann funktioniert das hier in E nicht mehr richtig.
Eins Champ.
Oder wie wäre es mit, wie wäre es mit den drei apokalyptischen Hovercrafts?
Hovercrafts.
Oh, ich höre, ich höre auf, ich höre auf, ist okay.
Ist gut.
Ich bin ruhig.
Ich verliere eh die letzten Gehirnzellen, während ich da spiele.
Kann das sein, dass hier alles, alles offen ist?
Dass einfach gar nichts an Gegnern am Start ist gerade?
Sieht so aus.
Es sieht so aus.
Guck mal, und wir bekommen sogar Muni.
Ja, fall doch mal um.
Okay, alles klar.
Das ist nice.
GG.
Da kann, also bei so einem Magazin, da kann man schon mal stehen bleiben.
Zehn Hitmarker easy, ja.
Ja, die Sache ist, das war ja nicht einer.
Das waren ja fünf unterschiedliche Gegner, die ich gehitmarkert habe.
Aber man kann in diesem Spiel, das ist auch was, was ich sehr fragwürdig finde,
man kann nicht mehr gescheit durch Gegner durchschießen.
Das finde ich, das finde ich wirklich doof.
Du griffst mich nicht.
Nope, no pass.
Okay, nice, der ist down.
Oh, oh, da kommt ein Panzermann.
Weg.
Hovercraft, Hovercraft, lasst ihn eben nicht mit.
Pass auf, ich stelle es mich jetzt in unser Hovercraft rein mit meinem.
Ich ziehe mich da jetzt ran, steige ein und bashe alles.
Oder auch nicht.
Leute, ich gucke nach der Runde in Chat.
Au.
Was zum?
Was?
Gut.
Nice.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wo er ist, der Dude.
Ob er da ist?
War er da?
Sieht alles so gleich aus.
Nein.
Äh, hier vielleicht?
Okay, ich blick da nicht durch.
Das ist, hat zu geringen Wiedererkennungswert.
Chat sagt, äh, hab das Gefühl, BF hat inzwischen eine Alle-Gewinn-Mentalität.
Ja?
Ja, ja, hast du recht.
Aber ich finde, das hatte Battlefield irgendwie, also zumindest seit Battlefield 3 eigentlich schon.
Okay.
Warum genau ist das jetzt nicht...
Ich finde, das hatte Battlefield seit 3 schon mit dem Unterschied, und das ist halt das riesen Ding,
dass du halt in Battlefield 3 noch viel rausholen konntest.
Aber in Battlefield 3 konnten auch Leute, die schlecht waren, sich nicht so gut verhalten.
Ja.
Die, die schlecht waren, durchaus ihren Spaß haben, finde ich zumindest.
Funktioniert hier überhaupt nichts, gerade mit irgendwie berghoch, sonst was.
Klar, in Battlefield 3, wenn du, wenn du, ähm, reingeschissen hast, das war schon frustrierend.
Aber du konntest auch so trotzdem Momente haben, wo du, wo du gut abgehst, ja.
Aber du hast schon recht, also diesmal haben sie es echt übertrieben.
Aber, ja, doch, diesmal haben sie es schon übertrieben.
Ich meine, diesmal, du siehst das ja, dass du keine Squads wechseln kannst.
Dass du keinen Scoreboard hast.
Dass du am Ende der Runde nicht mal angezeigt bekommst, wer gut und schlecht ist.
Dass sich keiner gekränkt fühlt.
Guck mal, könnt ihr euch gestern an die Runde Breakover erinnern?
70 Kills.
Irgendwie 70 Kills, 80 Assists.
Habt ihr, könnt ihr euch auch gestern dran erinnern?
Richtig krasse Runde.
Und am Ende, wisst ihr, was am Ende angezeigt wurde?
10 Hipfire Kills.
Ich hatte...
Jetzt stirbt er.
Ich hatte 70 Kills und 80 Assists.
Und es wird einfach mal angezeigt, 10 Hipfire Kills.
Ich meine, what the, what the fuck?
Was ist mit euch falsch?
Es gibt kein Scoreboard.
Ja, das hast du richtig verstanden.
Kein Scoreboard.
Du hast, ich zeige dir, was du als Scoreboard hast.
Du hast da nicht, nicht wirklich viel.
Du hast, also wenn ich hier durch bin und vielleicht das irgendwie überlebe, zeige ich dir das.
Boris!
Gekommnet!
Gekommnet Boris am Start.
Okay, alles down.
Einfach voll überrannt.
Easy.
Das Einzige, was du hast, ist, du hast einmal das hier.
Du siehst halt nichts, außer dein eigenes Squad.
Kein, kein nichts, dass sich nicht irgendeiner gekränkt fühlen könnte oder so.
Und wenn du Tab drückst, siehst du halt dein eigenes Squad.
Okay, das war's.
Das ist alles.
Was halt eigentlich, ja, viel zu wenig ist.
Wenn du mich fragst.
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass sie das jetzt ändern, weil der Aufschrei so groß war.
Und wisst ihr, was passiert?
Wisst ihr, was passiert, wenn die das ändern?
Dann sagen die Leute wieder, ich hab's doch gleich gesagt.
Gebt dem Spiel einfach ein bisschen Zeit.
Aber nein, daran liegt es nicht.
Wenn sowas gepatcht wird, dann einzig und allein, weil der Aufschrei zu groß war.
Weil das sind Dinger, die sind einfach...
Man, es ist immer der Gegner, wo du nicht hinguckst.
Immer der Gegner, der dich von der Seite wegschaut.
Weg, ähm, penetriert.
Dabei war das wieder eine richtig coole Aktion obendrauf.
Wir hätten jetzt fünf Kills machen können, aber nein.
Gibt's nicht.
Und wenn die das patchen...
Oh, nein, nein.
Und wie gesagt, wenn die das patchen, ist es nicht, weil sie es eingesehen haben,
sondern weil sie gedacht haben, fuck, die Leute flamen uns ja des Todes.
Moment.
Äh.
Entweder, entweder Boomer-Eis,
oder der war einfach schwarz mit der Wand verschwunden.
Holzen gerade.
Dachte, der ist im nächsten Raum.
Wahrscheinlich Boomer-Eis.
Was sagt ihr?
Hat man den gesehen, oder waren das safe?
Safe Boomer-Eis?
Okay.
Ich dachte es mir schon fast.
Wobei ich das halt nicht so genau nachvollziehen kann.
Weil, guckt euch mal Warzone an.
Warum ist hier keine Tür?
Ist hier wirklich keine Tür?
Gibt es hier nur zwei Türen?
Guckt euch mal Warzone an.
Warzone war...
Warzone war so der letzte große Hit,
der dann auch letztendgültig Battle Royale
vercasualisiert hat für Tante Brunhilde.
Aber trotzdem, Warzone hat immer noch richtig krasse Skill-Moves,
die du machen kannst.
Das darf man nicht vergessen.
Das ist zwar mit SBMM und allem easy einsteigerfreundlich,
aber du kannst immer noch richtig,
richtig heftige Moves machen.
Von wo überhaupt?
Ach da, von Boris.
Easy, easy clap, Boris.
Und ich sag euch, Leute,
das Game hat auch Skill-Best-Matchmaking hier.
Das will nur keiner wahrhaben.
Das ist...
Ich merk das.
Ich spiel hier doch nicht gegen absolute
Kack-Noobs, die vor einem Tag angefangen haben.
Oder vor zwei Tagen.
Kann mir keiner erzählen.
Die können...
Vor allem, weil die alle schon gerade aussehen,
ausamen können, ist das nicht der Fall.
So die richtig Ultra-Kack-Noobs,
die können ja nicht mal keine drei Meter gerade ausamen.
Wenn das ein richtiger Kack-Noob gewesen wäre,
den hätte ich gehippt feiert.
Den hätte ich gehippt feiert.
Und er hätte mich nicht getroffen.
Uääh.
Das hat wieder wunderbar funktioniert.
So, wir können jetzt unsere Massive-Hook-
Grappling-Hook-Moves machen, sobald er aufgeladen ist.
In der Hoffnung, er geht nicht kaputt.
Weiß.
Doch, er geht nicht.
Sehr, sehr schön.
Da ist ein Panzer.
Panz-Man.
30 Millimeter geschützt, jawoll.
Meinst du, dass man das Spiel noch retten kann?
Tja.
Ich glaub, das ist die größte Frage,
die sich alle gerade stellen.
Also meine Meinung dazu ist,
also das Spiel hat keinen sonderlich guten Kern,
so wie es jetzt ist.
Das einfachste, was man...
What the fuck?
Das ist einfach verschwunden.
Okay.
Das einzige, was man jetzt machen kann, ist...
Also was ich machen würde,
ich würde ihm die Maps
neue Grenzen ziehen und aus einer großen Map
einfach 1-3 kleine Maps machen.
Oh, der ist nicht gestorben, Alter.
Der hat 3 Headshots oder so gehabt.
Nix.
Jetzt können wir aber MP9 spielen.
Also die könnten aus einer Map
1-3 kleinere Maps machen,
weil guck mal, dieses Areal hier
und drumherum könnte man vielleicht
sogar eine 32-64 Spieler
hier so dieses Areal,
eine halbwegs gute 32 Mann,
64 Mann, 48 Mann
Map draus machen.
Hier oben auch draus
und schon hätte man zwei.
Spiel eine Runde mit einem anderen Account.
Ja klar, ich kaufe mir das Spiel auch nochmal
auf einem anderen Account.
Oh, das macht so viel Damage auf die Entfernung.
Okay, massive, massive big brain move.
Alter, warum ist das so broken?
Ich meine, der Grappling Hook ist das geilste Attachment,
aber wenn, dann sollte er halt mal funktionieren.
So, wir gehen jetzt da drauf.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, wo was ist.
Vielleicht hier.
Okay, nice.
Hey, ich glaube, 128 Spieler
auf Armored Kill würde besser funktionieren
als hier.
Ich möchte das öffnen, please.
Machen wir wieder zu.
Wie kann man
hier innen drinnen nicht weiter?
Ah, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht offen genug.
Da haben sie sich gedacht, nope.
Seriously?
Alter, ich hasse dieses Game.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Die Dinger von der MP9 sind
straight durch den Kopf geflogen.
Das letzte war PP-Guard, aber das davor
ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Ja, ich finde auch, 128 Spieler waren
nicht die krasseste Idee.
Alter, könnt ihr mal sterben.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich hin soll.
Einfach so auf links-rechts laufen.
Hier.
Geht hier was? Oben drauf?
Bashen, Alter, bashen.
Oder muss ich doch wieder PP-Guard 29 raushauen?
128 Spieler.
Also mehr Flaggen wäre...
Patrick, ich muss sagen, auf die Idee bin ich noch gar nicht gekommen.
128 Spieler
mit mehr Flaggen?
Ich glaube, das wäre gar keine so schlechte Idee.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich finde den Ansatz...
Hier drei kleine...
Guck mal, hier kannst du...
Da kannst du eine kleine 64-Spieler-Map draus machen.
32, 38, 44, 64 Spieler.
Und da, den Rest der Map kannst du einfach...
Dieses Areal hier...
Das wäre eine ganz gute...
Vielleicht das hier noch dabei, was auch immer das ist.
Das wäre tatsächlich eine ganz gute 64-Spieler-Map.
Mal anderen Sitz.
Ich spray da jetzt einfach mal rein.
Okay, da musst du Shroud sein, dass du das hitterst hier, glaube ich.
Okay, wechseln wir wieder.
Alter, was machst denn du hier?
Schneiber, du.
Von hinten kommt irgendwas.
Oh, der Pantsman ist hinter uns!
Der Pantsman ist hinter uns!
Das war aber close.
Das war richtig close.
Der hält uns gerade richtig...
Oh ne, da ist der nächste Pantsman am Start.
Ich hoffe einfach, wir überleben das.
Okay, nice.
Nichts geht jetzt.
Macht der Boomerarm nicht mehr mit.
Okay, wir gehen raus.
Und vielleicht haben wir Glück.
Und können hier hoch.
Nein. Nein.
Ohne zu sterben.
Lull.
Was ist der Mehrwert von so vielen Spielern?
Ja, das musst du Dice fragen.
Das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Das verstehe ich auch nicht so genau.
Also...
Ja doch, doch ich verstehe es.
Ich weiß, was der Mehrwert ist.
Der Mehrwert ist, dass man marketingtechnisch gut damit...
Warum werde ich denn hier unten gesport, Mann?
Dass man marketingtechnisch gut damit werben kann.
Ich bin stuck.
Was zum...
Okay, game.
Sag mal.
Was ist mit diesem Spiel los, Mann?
Was ist mit diesem Spiel los?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Das ist gerade...
Ja, das sieht aus, als ist die Leiter-Hitbox einfach ans Meter nebendran.
Wahnsinn.
Gut, dass du uns was gesagt hast, Sunnys.
Ja, die 34 normalen Kills, die interessieren keinen.
11 als Passenger, die sind wichtig.
Outstanding Performance.
Welche Squad? Habt ihr geguckt?
Welche Squad? Welcher Platz?
Welchen Platz im Squad-Ranking waren wir?
Hat irgendjemand aufgepasst?
Hier? Ja, das ist okay.
Wie gesagt, mit Top 5 bin ich zufrieden.
Top 5 ist in dem Spiel...
Weil, als Infanterie-Squad, du spielst ja gegen die ganzen Heli-Owner und Hovercraft-Owner und so.
Und ich spiele so gut wie nie Hovercraft.
Und wir fliegen so gut wie nie Heli.
Das einzige, was wir in den Runden gemacht haben, ist am Anfang ein bisschen Jeep gefahren.
Ähm...
Biotech?
Dazu kann ich bloß sagen...
Wo ist die Frage? Hier?
Also sprich...
Hey Leute, soll man sich als alter Battlefield-3 und Battlefield-4-Fan
das Game zulegen oder lieber noch warten?
Also ich kann dir da meine Meinung zu sagen.
Und die lautet...
Nein, du solltest dir das besser nicht zulegen,
wenn du Battlefield-3 und Battlefield-4-Fan bist.
Das heißt, du bist im aktuellen Zustand nicht.
Und ob der Zustand sich jemals großartig bessert...
Hm...
Ach, oh, Discarded!
Sehr gut, Discarded!
Das haben wir ja schon lange nicht mehr gespielt.
Und Discarded, die erste...
Die erste Flags in Discarded sind auch so gut platziert.
Also ich kann mir so richtig das Design-Meeting, das Daily-Scrum...
Ich kann mir richtig gut das Daily-Scrum vorstellen von DICE,
Wo sie die Discarded...
Breakthrough besprochen haben.
Da kam so der erste DICE-Typ...
Hat gesagt, guck mal, wir haben hier eine riesige Map ohne was drauf.
Wie machen wir da Breakthrough?
Dann hat er gesagt, weißt du was?
Mach einfach da zwei Container mehr hin und stell die Flagge hin.
Die Spieler merken schon nicht, dass das eine doofe Idee ist.
Dann hat der Chef gesagt, Jungs...
Gehaltserhöhung.
Poggers Idee.
Und jetzt die Map im Spiel, jetzt müssen wir mitleben.
Das war einfach agiles Daily-Scrum...
Was uns das gebracht hat.
Wir sind am Tag einfach nicht da.
Warum muss man sich eigentlich die Sprüche jedes Mal neu anhören?
Gut, wir können kein MP9 spielen auf die Range.
Das geht nicht.
Es ist ja aber auch komisch, in einem Spiel,
was mehr Battlefield-Ranges hat,
also mehr Range hat,
als jedes andere Battlefield,
hat man sich so überlegt,
wir machen alle Waffen auf Range scheiße.
Hat irgendjemand diesen...
5Head, 6Head, 11Head Gedankengang verstehen?
Vielleicht verstehe ich auch diese
Obvious-Genialität nicht.
Das wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Aber es sind ja alle Waffen,
bis auf die DMR, scheiße auf Range.
Also, PPGA 29 und DMR.
Der Rest ist Trash auf Range.
Sniper lasse ich jetzt mal außen vor,
weil offensichtlich, dass zumindest die
One-Shot-Sniper auf Range ganz okay ist.
Aber von den normalen Waffen,
es ist ja eigentlich alles Trash auf Range,
bis auf zwei Waffen.
Oder bis auf eine Waffe und eine Waffenkategorie.
Oh, guck mal, ein Hovercraft.
Wer hätte das gedacht, dass da ein Hovercraft kommt?
Das kommt ja so selten vor.
Ah, ein Armor-Plate.
Sehr gut.
Er hat mich aus-PBX-t.
Habe auch nicht gut getroffen.
So, was ist denn hier los?
Warum sind hier schon wieder so viele Gegner-Fahrzeuge?
Da brauchen wir jetzt Anti-Fahrzeug-Granaten.
Das ist auch so eine Big-Brain-Design-Idee, ne, Leute?
Anti-Fahrzeug-Granaten?
Ich meine, the fuck?
Anti-Fahrzeug-Raketen? Okay.
Aber zielsuchende Anti-Fahrzeug-Granaten?
Weiß nicht.
Aber eins kann ich sagen,
nachdem ich heute Hazard Zone gespielt habe,
muss ich sagen,
das Specialist-Konzept
nun deutlich besser.
Das Specialist-Konzept
klappt in Hazard Zone
klappt tatsächlich deutlich besser.
Seht ihr, wie die abgeht, die Granate?
Die flutscht mal richtig.
Ist Hazard Zone Battle Royale?
Nee.
Ich versuch mal Hesation zu erklären
Also
Du hast random auf der Map
Irgendwelche Festplatten, die gespawnt sind
Nein
Und es spawnen
Acht Teams rein, die die Festplatten sammeln sollen
Dafür hat man so einen Scanner
Da guckt man durch und sieht, wo die sind
Und dann geht man da hin
Und sammelt die
Und alle, frag mir nicht
Zehn Minuten oder so, oder fünf Minuten
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht
Ha! Ha!
Ha! Gutes Spiel
Gutes Spiel
Und alle paar Minuten kommt so ein Hubschrauber
Und wenn du diesen Hubschrauber
Reingehst, fliegt er dich raus
Und du bekommst
Rewards
Vielleicht sind Battlefield Patches drauf
Krieg ich ein Rätsel, Leute?
Krieg ich ein Rätsel?
Ihr Ehrenmänner
Ach ne, ich kann nicht gerätselt werden, weil ich stecke ja in der Wand
Hab ich ganz vergessen, das geht ja nicht
Wenn man auch nur einen Pixel in der Wand steckt, kann man nicht wiederbelebt werden
Man muss es ja nicht übertreiben
In Bad Company 2
Das war so nicht geplant, by the way
In Bad Company 2 konnte man durch die Wand wiederbeleben
Das war vielleicht auch nicht so gut
Aber ich finde, es hat seinen Charme
Dass man wiederbelebt werden kann
Was hier in dem Spiel oftmals nicht funktioniert
Und das Wiederbeleben ist schon ziemlich schwierig
Ist der Typ jetzt down?
Ich glaube, der ist down
Okay, nice
Ich mag die Base hier lieber
Weil hier ist der Kran
Und mit dem Kran
Ey
Clusterfuck
Übrigens
Ich muss euch jetzt dazu mal
Einen Quote zeigen
Aus meinem Video
Und dann müsst ihr mir sagen
Max, du bist einfach nur Boomer Kackknut
Mittlerweile
Oder ihr müsst sagen, das ist eine doofe Idee gewesen
Was der Typ geschrieben hat
Und zwar
Oh fuck, da kamen ja mittlerweile schon wieder so viele
Okay, ich find's jetzt
Hier, hier, da war's
Chrome
Genau
Also, ich sag bei 10, 5, 10
Für einen Gegner, den du siehst, sehen dich 5
Und er sagt, da braucht man einfach die Reactions für
Also ich hätte, dass ich das überlebe
Ich hätte einfach die Reactions gebraucht
Hätte ich die Reactions gehabt
Hätte ich die jetzt alle wegbashen können
Aber ich hatte die Reactions einfach nicht
Wie steht ihr dazu?
Die Reactions fehlen einfach
Vielleicht, vielleicht sollte ich
Vielleicht sollte ich ein bisschen mehr
Nein, nicht rausfahren, Hovercraft
Wir müssen hier spawnen
Nice
Sehr gut
Weiter jetzt
Wir müssen da hin
Ey, es ist wieder durchgeflogen
Meine Güte, Mann
Wie soll man auf 40 FPS
Das kommt ja auch noch dabei
Bei den FPS krasse Reactions haben
Ja
, ja
Ja, ja
Oder hier oben oder da
Nee, Dach
Die sind auf dem Dach
Dachstelz
So war das nicht geplant
Ich wollte eigentlich hier rausspringen, aber
Der Ball hat mich weg
War so klar
Vielleicht kriege ich einen Rätsel hinter dir
Das wäre schon sehr nice
Oh
Guckt euch das mal an
Teammates des Jahres
Sind die jetzt unter uns oder
Oder wo oder was, Mann
Aber hier Teammates des Jahres
Oh, was da oben
Holen wir ihn, hier
Zack
Captain Poggers am Start
Jetzt geht's, jetzt geht's rein
Einfach nicht
Die Reactions
Denn da hinten hätte ich jetzt theoretisch auch
Instant headshotten müssen
Sind einfach nicht die Reactions da
Obviously
Musst halt reacten
Das war übrigens nicht der, den wir gesehen haben
Das war noch ein ganz anderer
Typ
Ups
Ey, das Spiel macht mich fertig
Zieh halt auf den Kopf
Just, just
Just do it, just headshot
Just don't lose
Okay, nee, da machst du nix mehr
Ihr seht, das Karnet ist richtig gut
Am Anfang
Wär das gebasht?
Nein, nein, nein, nein
Just click the heads, so sieht's aus
Easy
Krasser Teamplayer, guckt mal an, der hat Armorplates verteilt
Richtig krasser Teamplayer
Massiver Teamplayer, würd ich sogar sagen
So, ich muss da mal hoch
Und ein Stückchen fliegen
Weil ansonsten bringt mir der Wingsuit ja gar nix
Falls ich, falls ich da überhaupt
Na, das geht natürlich nicht
PP29
Ihr seht ja, eigentlich ist die PP29
Genau das, wie die Waffen für das Spiel sein müssen
Du brauchst mehr Munition
Weil du hast halt einfach immer mal
Die Waffen für das Spiel sein müssen
Du brauchst 40 Gegner
Die du potenziell schießen musst
Und du brauchst Waffen, die auf Range
Halbwegs brauchbar sind
Also das Waffendesign versteh ich überhaupt nicht
Du hast
Du hast nichts
Außer die PP29 und DMRs
Die dir so irgendwie so
Weil die Assault Rifles halt einfach mal Hardcore sacken
Nichts, was du eigentlich auf diese Ranges
Gescheit spielen kannst
Da frage ich mich auch so, okay
Wer ist auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen
Das ist
Das ist so gut
Das ist so eine gute Idee ist
Oh, Moritz, ich hol dich
Moritz, wieder rauf hier
Nein
Oh
Covid-Impfung reingejagt
Ich hol dich wieder
Teammate des Monats Award
Nein
Pass auf, ich genieße die große Deckung, die hier ist
Oh, diese Deckung
Ich hab mich gleich viel
Ich hab mich gleich viel sicherer gefühlt
Hinter der Deckung
Das sind die Booster-Shots, genauer
Leicht paar Motion-Sensoren mal hier rumfeuern
Motion-Sensor-Feuern
So, wo sind denn Gegner hier, zeigt mal
Sieht man hier irgendwas
Seht ihr, wo ich bin auf der Map
Chat, wo bin ich auf der Map, seht ihr es
Wo bin ich
Ich bin da
Wem das nicht aufgefallen ist, da
Ich bin, ah, ah
Ach, da hinten ist er, Mann
Also, falls, falls ihr es nicht erkannt habt
Ich wäre da gewesen, hier
Obviously
Die Heal-Operatorin findest du zu schwach
Nee, find ich gar nicht
Du meinst hier die deutsche Oma
Das ist eigentlich eines der besten
Ich zeig dir gleich mal, warum die richtig gut ist
Ich switch gleich mal
Erinnert mich dran, falls ich es vergesse
Ihr wisst, mein Hirn ist nicht mehr so voll bei der Sache hier
Wenn ich spielen muss nebenbei
Die ist richtig gut
Ich zeig
Okay, ich zeig dir gleich, warum
Ich versuche mal dich... Hallo, warum...
Das Game, Mann
Das Game
Sie kann doch mit der Pistole auf Range heilen
So, also warum ich die
Warum ich die Oma richtig gut finde ist
Das, Mann
Gehen wir da jetzt mit
Vielleicht komme ich hier noch rein
Vielleicht habe ich Glück
Kann ich beim Serious Max oder beim
Spawn, oh nee
Ähm
Ach, auf Range retzen können, okay
So, weil du kannst mit der Pistole
Du kannst auf die Erde schießen und drüber laufen und dich heilen
Ich mach das aber nicht, weil das manchmal verbuggt ist
Aber das ist eigentlich richtig OP
Ich persönlich spiele aber lieber mit Mobility Specialists
Als mit der Oma
Aber trotzdem würde ich sagen
Also wenn ich ein Tier Ranking machen müsste
Von den Specialists
Würde ich sagen
Maria Falk ist S-Tier
Maria Falk und Sundance sind S-Tier
Ähm
Webster ist Art A-Tier
Weil er eigentlich der beste ist
Weil er eigentlich der beste
Specialist ist, wie ich finde
Nur, dass die Maps zu wenig Möglichkeiten
Geben für seinen Grappling Hook
Alter, ich hab noch nicht
Ich hab noch nicht mal geplant, wo hier irgendetwas schießt
Hopp, da kriege ich nix
Medic
Oh nee, der hat mich tatsächlich
Der hat mich geholt
Wahrscheinlich
Jawoll, gib ihm, gib ihm, gib ihm
Jawoll, huge, huge, massive Spawn
Okay, das war keine gute Idee
Hier oben drauf zu gehen
Der hat mich auf den Sack gleich
Jawoll
Guck, jetzt kannst du einfach drüber laufen
Hast du es gesehen? Das ist richtig pock
Richtig pock
Wir verlieren Leute
Wir verlieren Leute, habt ihr das gehört?
Wenn die das sagt, dann weiß man
Es ist ernst
Dann ist es ernst
Okay, wir müssen hier weg, das geht nicht
Kann ich
Ich sollte mal meinen
Raketenwerfer nachladen
Ich meine, du kannst halt
Irgendwohin
Ja klar, na klar
Schon drauf geschossen
Bevor er um die Ecke gekommen ist
Oder anders gerade
Wie lange bleibt der Heal auf dem Boden?
Das ist eine gute Frage, das weiß ich nicht
Das weiß ich nicht
Oh nee, hier kann mich keiner ratzen
Nee, nee, lass, lass, lass, Leute
Das kann mich
Das weiß ich nicht
Da bin ich überfragt
Wie lange das auf dem Boden bleibt
Wahrscheinlich nicht allzu lang
Squad, wir sacken die Runde
Aber ich auch
Ich weiß aber auch nicht, was ich hier
Großartig anders machen soll gerade
Oh, Hovercraft, nice
Ich renne jetzt hier einfach mal hinter
Vielleicht
Trinkt das was
Hier, big tree stells
Game
F, ich drücke F für Mele
Hallo, F
F
Ich will den Zaun messen
Alter, so abfucktes Spiel, Mann
Der macht keinen Nahkampfangriff
Den Zaun messen, ja
Da geht er kaputt
Das ist kein Nahkampfangriff, der geht einfach nicht
Es ist einfach
Nicht möglich Nahkampfangriff zu machen
Aber wir haben gewonnen
Pains Champ
So ein Pains Champ
Ich fand die Animation in der Beta
Wo die mit der Faust auf den Zaun
Yeah
Wo die mit der Faust
Auf diesen Zaun gehauen haben und der Zaun ist dann
Explodiert, fand ich viel besser
Das hatte ich auch schon, dass linke und rechte Maustaste
Nicht funktioniert haben
Das merkst du halt, wenn du nicht schießen kannst
Oder nicht ADS gehen kannst
Das ist so kaputt
Alles
Was macht die Omi da?
Die heilt, Leute
Eigentlich heilt die sich zum größten Teil selbst
Wie findest du die XP Vergabe?
Hab ich jetzt
Hab ich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so viel
Augenmerk drauf gelegt
Weil ich meistens mit Motion Sensor unterwegs bin
Dementsprechend relativ viele Assists hab
Aber
Eigentlich ist es so
Eigentlich ist es okay
Weil man levelt eh saumäßig schnell
Ich mein ich bin jetzt was?
45?
Chat fragt, wieso ist der Sani eine Oma und keine Frau mit blonden Haaren?
Wahrscheinlich wäre das zu Schwedisch
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht, aber...
Das muss ja möglichst divers und international sein
Der Cast of Characters
Da kannst du nicht einfach
Schwedisches blondes Grill reinmachen
Oder Mercy in Overwatch
Schweizer, blondes Schweizer Grill
Das geht nicht
Was kommt denn jetzt für eine Map?
Hoffentlich mal eine gescheite Map
Manifest zum Beispiel wäre sehr nice
Wenn jetzt Manifest kommt
Oder vielleicht
Ah, Manifest, vielleicht Renewal
Manifest, POG
Vielleicht sogar Attacker
Force Champ
Vielleicht dürfen wir Attacker spielen
Das wäre sehr nice
Manifest Attacker, das ist eigentlich die einzige Map, die ich wirklich gerne spiele
Manifest Attacker
Praege, Leute, Praege, Praege
Praege, Chat, Praege
Praege
Manifest Attacker
Die Sprüche sind so dumm
Okay, okay
Praege, Praege
Ja, Alter, laber nicht
Ich will sehen, ob ich Attacker oder Defender bin
Ich bin Attacker! Bäm!
Jawoll!
POG, Attacker Manifest
Sehr gut, das mag ich
Was heißt das jetzt?
Praege ist dieses Emote aus dem Chat
Der
Der macht halt Praege
Zedge macht er, Praege macht er
Was gibt es noch für ge Emotes?
Außer pipiga
Zedge, Praege
Badge, Badge, Vogue
Madge
Ja, das habe ich aber nicht
Oh, guck mal
Oh, voll Haus hier
Wir fliegen jetzt in die Luft, Leute
Ich sage euch, wir haben noch 10 Sekunden zu leben
Dann sind wir down
Weil irgendwas merkwürdiges passiert
Oder wir gegen die Wand fahren
Übrigens jetzt hier mal ernsthaft
Das ist das beste Geschoss für das Auto
Was wir hier haben
30 Millimeter
30 Millimeter Geschoss
Monka, Alter
Die machen mich fertig hier
Die krassen Drivers
Die krassen Drivers hier
Hier
Aber richtig, Leute
Aber richtig
Monka, Steer
Glaubst du auch, dass Battlefield 20
das Spiel des Jahres werden könnte?
Natürlich
Also bei diesem grandiosen Launch
Und dadurch, dass das Jahr
ja quasi fast zu Ende ist
Also mit diesem Launch
Da ist ja quasi Game of the Year
fast schon gesichert
Vielleicht kriegt es auch den deutschen Computerspielepreis
Der ist ja international sehr begehrt
Der ist ja international sehr begehrt, habe ich gehört
Den wollen sie alle haben
Der ist so begehrt, dass die Preisempfänger
noch nicht mal erscheinen, um den Preis entgegen zu nehmen
Wird es das letzte Battlefield sein?
Nö, wahrscheinlich nicht
Huck
Mann
Warum fickt mich immer einer von der Seite
Egal wo du hinguckst
Das Spiel kriegt den, was für ein Ding
Den silbernen Bravo Otto
Gab es das früher mal
Da war ich wahrscheinlich noch nicht
Wo ich mich dafür interessiert habe
Oh guck mal da
Da nehmen wir jetzt MP9
Wir müssen immer diese Kackwaffe spielen
Guck mal, und jetzt kommt sogar
Schalldämpfer drauf
Stealthmodus aktiviert
Krasser Hacker, man
Richtig krasser Hacker
Richtig krasser Hacker, man
Ich wollte da übrigens
NICHT hochklettern, sag ich euch
Nicht hochklettern, sag ich euch
Ist Clidem eigentlich schneller als
Normales Laufen?
Hm, das ist eine gute Frage.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob du mit Laufen, Sliden, Laufen, Sliden irgendwie schneller bist,
aber du hast einen Vorteil, die Gegner hinten dich nicht so einfach.
Deswegen finde ich schon, dass es nicht verkehrt zu sliden, wenn man sliden kann.
Welches Battlefield spielt ihr im Moment?
Das ist 2042, das ist das...
Latest and greatest Battlefield experience, wenn du nach DICE gehst.
Ja, ja, bashen, Alter, bashen.
Oh, wir wurden gehackermanned.
Richtige, richtige Hacksaw am Start.
Okay, hier sieht man wieder, du kannst nur PPA 29 spielen.
Ich habe keine Range, um irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise irgendwas zu killen.
Ich habe hier nice Flanks, stell es am Start.
Aber kann nichts machen. Ich habe keine Range, Mann.
Dankeschön, dass ich das Ding ins Gesicht bekommen habe.
Ich bekomme immer gerne Raketenwürfe ins Gesicht.
Ich finde das richtig geil.
Geht mir immer einer ab.
Seht ihr, wie genau man da sich anstrengen muss zu aimen, um mit dem Ding was zu killen?
Mega anstrengend. Einfach PPA 29 draufspammen, um gut ist.
Ja.
Nice.
Ach, da. Obvious.
Obvious.
Obviously ist da jemand.
Da hätte man ja mal mit rechnen können.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Durch hier.
Achtung.
Massive brain move.
Fuck.
Da kommt gleich was.
Nice.
Oh, ich habe keine Healpacks mehr. Fuck.
Aber vielleicht, Leute, vielleicht könnt ihr bei mir rein spawnen.
Ich bleibe safe. Nice.
Dieses fucking Game, Alter.
Okay.
Hast du das Halo schon getestet?
Nein.
Ich habe das seit fünf Tagen, also seit ich es runtergeladen habe und nicht probiert.
Aber ich will es unbedingt.
Mal endlich ausprobieren, weil ich glaube, ich drehe langsam durch.
Ich verliere wirklich die letzten Gehirnzellen, wenn ich das hier spiele.
Warum kriegen wir eigentlich so extremst auf den Sack?
Macht mehr Spaß als Belfry.
Wie ist denn das, Leute?
In Halo 3 war es halt so, dass du als Halo Noob erst mal zwei Monate üben musstest, bis du irgendwie halbwegs was auf die Reihe gekriegt hast.
Wie ist das in dem Halo?
Also kann man das auch als Halo Noob?
Kann man da reinkommen, ohne dass man erst mal richtig krassen Crying machen muss?
Weil mein letztes Halo ist halt schon ein bisschen her.
Am PC kommt man generell reicht rein.
Ja, ich glaube, das war ja auch eines der Ziele, die sie hatten, dass man dieses Halo auch jetzt als Einsteiger da erst mal ganz gut spielen kann.
Ey, das Spiel ist einfach Müll.
Was willst du?
Twitch TV.
Okay, den Typen müssen wir killen.
Den Typen müssen wir killen.
Twitch TV im Namen.
Warum muss man bei Halo 3 so stark Cryen?
Weil Halo so einen ganz speziellen Flow hatte und die Gegner halt auch viel ausgehalten haben.
Und dementsprechend musstest du erstens dich schon wirklich gut an Xbox Controller gewöhnen.
Alter!
Kann das...
Einfach mal...
Was ist denn hier los?
Ach, das ist ein fucking Ranger.
Das ist gar kein Gegner.
Es kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass ich hier gegen absolute Noobs spiele.
Das kann mir keiner erzählen.
Das ist...
Das ist SBMM, Leute.
Nee, wobei, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube nicht, dass es SBMM ist.
Ich glaube, es ist einfach das beschissenste Map-Design, was es jemals in der Battlefield gegeben hat.
Maps...
Ich meine, die Maps passen so gar nicht zu der Spieleranzahl.
Der Typ kann einfach da unkontestet oben stehen, ohne dass ihm irgendwas passiert.
Ich meine...
The fuck, man!
Geh mir nicht auf den Sack.
Jetzt bin ich mad, gell, Alter.
Mein Gott, ey.
Was hat man sich dabei gedacht?
Ich kriege wirklich Anfälle gerade.
Ich habe mich erstmal eingebannt, Leute.
Erstmal Rage-Ban.
Alter, das kann es doch wirklich nicht sein, ey.
Und da spricht entspannt reden, bringt nichts mehr, Leute.
Was ist das hier?
Bad Company 2?
Oh, nee, nee, nee.
Wenn ich jetzt Bad Company 2 spiele, geht das gar nicht.
Oh, fuck!
Säge!
Ins Maul.
Endlich mal ein Nahkampf-Kill.
Gib ihm!
Bam!
In your face!
Okay, der Typ ist down.
Wie lange dauert ein Melee-Kill?
Sehr lange.
Das war ein Absicht.
Also, wenn du lang drückst...
Wenn du lang drückst, dann macht er so einen komischen Melee-Kill ansonsten nicht.
Sorry an den, den ich irgendwie gebannt habe eben.
Äh, äh, gemutet habe.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen aufgeregt über das Game.
Was, glaube ich, echt verständlich ist, wenn man sich das anguckt.
Ah!
Guck mal da hinten.
Da wird schon geschneibt.
Wie verrückt.
Vielleicht können wir mal irgendwas spawnen.
Wenigstens so.
Ja, komm.
Takedowns sind drin für Cosmetic Items.
Korrekt.
Hauptsächlich für Cosmetic Items sind hier drin.
Das ist richtig.
Okay.
Boah.
Da wollte er mich einfach mit dem M5 in die Luft sprengen.
Okay.
Einfach so.
Hat er sich gedacht.
Ja.
Brake.
Oh, guck mal.
Ich habe Heidi Klum gekillt.
Ach, nee.
Heidi Klum.
Ah, nicht Heidi Klum.
Heidi.
Okay.
Ich kann hier nicht raus.
Wenn ich hier...
Wenn ich meinen Kopf hier rausstecke, dann bin ich deadge.
Aber richtig massiv deadge.
Ah, intelligenter Roboter.
Ich muss hier oben rumstellen.
Was anderes geht nicht.
Ah, der ist down.
Nix wie weg.
Ah, nein.
Ah, Mist.
Ich dachte, man kommt da rüber.
Nochmal kurz rauf.
Und hopp.
Oh, da unten.
Guck mal da.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Irgendwas schießt hier auf mich.
Ich habe gar keine Ahnung.
Was?
Der hat sich jetzt auch gedacht.
Wo the fuck kommt der Typ her?
Haben wir uns gegenseitig gekillt?
Ja, wir haben uns gegenseitig gekillt.
Findet ihr es auch so schwierig, in diesem Battlefield mehr als drei Kills in Folge zu machen?
Das ist nahezu unmöglich.
Unmöglich, mehr als drei Kills in Folge zu machen.
Wir haben es, Leute.
Wir haben es.
Brage hat geholfen.
Einzig und allein, weil der Chat gebraet hat.
Wuh.
Die haben übrigens auch die Strecke, die du zurücklegen kannst, mit dem Fallschirmseiter-Beta, glaube ich, genervt.
In der Beta konntest du total weit fliegen.
Mit dem Fallschirm.
Zumindest kommt es mir so vor, ob es wirklich so ist.
Ja, gut.
Entschuldige.
Hier liegen ganz viele...
Ah, nice.
Okay, ich dachte, es geht vielleicht durch.
Hä, man kann es ja mal probieren.
Ey, Max, was für Settings spielst du?
Wenn ja, läuft es flüssig.
Ja, siehst du da oben, ja.
80 FPS.
Ich würde es jetzt nicht als ultraflüssig bezeichnen.
Gerade zwischenzeitliche Slowdowns sind ganz, ganz eklig.
Exquisiter Spawn.
Sehr gut da.
Sehr gut reingespornt unter der Erde.
Oh.
Ach ja, hier ist ja viel Deckung.
Hier ist ja viel Deckung.
Sehr gute Sache.
Wenn ich tauchen könnte, dann könnte man auch...
Also wie in Battlefield 4.
Also in Battlefield 4 konnte man ja tauchen, das ging.
Aber das haben die Leute in 2042 verlernt.
Ah, ja, guck mal da.
Was?
Wo bin ich überhaupt?
Ach ja, das geht übrigens auch.
Wer es zum ersten Mal sieht, wird sich jetzt ein Upkick wehen, aber das ist normal in dem Spiel.
Das Hovercraft kann alles.
Das ist gepanzert wie ein Tank.
Das ist mobil.
Das hat Firepower wie sonst was.
Hovercraft ist einfach das Beste.
So, vielleicht kommen wir hier irgendwie rauf.
Ach, guck mal, auf der anderen Seite sind die.
Für sowas ist der Grappling-Hook wirklich nice.
Da macht es richtig Spaß.
Deswegen finde ich, ist das der beste Specialist.
Leider bieten die Maps zu wenig.
Deswegen sage ich nicht, dass das Estia ist.
Estia ist Maria, Falk und Sundance, finde ich.
Okay, wo genau sind die jetzt?
Haben die Leute, die Konsole spielen, auch so Probleme?
Ja, im Prinzip, ja.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Da steht so ein Kackturm.
Wo ist der andere Typ hin?
Ich höre was über mir.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo der angeblich gewesen sein soll.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Okay, hier erstmal da rein.
So.
Wo gehen wir denn jetzt hin?
B1?
Wo ist denn das andere?
B2 haben wir schon.
Ja, bleibt ja nur B1.
Oh, da kommt ein Auto.
Sehr viel.
Okay, ich glaube, wir müssen B1.
Was anderes bleibt uns gar nicht übrig.
Verlieren das.
Natürlich blöd.
Jetzt wäre Sundance nice.
Jetzt wäre Sundance ziemlich pock.
Mit dem Wing-Suit hierdurch.
Da steht einfach mal jemand.
Obvious, dass der da stand.
Na klar.
Da muss man schon mal checken, dass der da steht.
Ja, das kommt auch noch dabei, dass das teilweise durchfliegt.
Wir hatten doch schon alles erobert eben.
Hä?
Wie geht denn das jetzt?
Komm, wir machen nochmal MP9.
Oh, Mattress, Pogger-Spawn.
Oh, Alter.
Ich weiß nicht, was hier abgeht, aber...
Alter, Hacker-Man.
Hat er mich gesehen?
Lad nach, please.
Okay, nein, der hat keinen Bock.
Okay, das war von mir PP-Gard.
Das war PP-Gard.
Das hätte ich täglich eins haben müssen.
Oh, ich weiß, wo wir waren.
Da oben ist er.
Mann, es fickt dich immer einer, den du nicht siehst.
Es ist einfach schrecklich.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Ehrenmänner hier.
Richtige Ehrenmänner.
Richtige Ehrenmanns.
Aber wo jetzt was ist...
Weiß ich nicht.
Da fliegt was runter.
Okay, nice.
Motion-Sensor.
Ja, den können wir...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich weiß nicht genau, von wo.
Was zum...
Game, come on.
Irgendwann ist es mit Vertikalität doch auch mal gut.
Äh, Wasserfahrzeug.
Ja, du kannst Hovercraft spielen.
Hovercraft ist ja alles in einem.
Das ist eigentlich...
Jetzt verstehe ich es.
Das ist der Eleven-Head-Move von DICE.
Wisst ihr, warum es Hovercrafts gibt?
Weil die zu faul waren, Schiffe einzubauen.
Und die haben sich einfach gedacht, wir machen ein Hovercraft.
Dann brauchen wir weniger Panzer.
Und wir brauchen keine Schiffe machen.
Alter, Big-Brain-Move überhaupt.
Jetzt habe ich das endlich...
Von wo hätte ich überhaupt beschossen?
Jetzt habe ich das endlich verstanden, Mann.
Und ich habe ernsthaft keine Ahnung, von wo ich beschossen werde.
Ich checke es nicht.
Die hatten zu wenig Zeit für Schiffe.
Die haben ja nur drei...
Okay, das geht nicht.
Du musst PP29 spielen.
Du kannst nichts anderes spielen.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Ging nicht.
Hatte keinen Bock.
Hatte gedacht, nope, no pass.
Okay, sehr gut.
Runtersliden.
In den Ass geschudet.
Das ist viel zu vertikal.
Guck mal, wo ist hier was?
Wo geht hier was?
Oben bestimmt.
Der stellt mich gleich von oben ab.
Sag's euch.
Hier sind ja offensichtlich welche.
Vielleicht gehe ich oben auf den Kran.
Ja, ja, ja.
Oh, wäre das nice, wenn ich den spotten könnte.
Sehr gut.
Gleich haben wir es, Leute.
PPGuard Squad hat gesiegt.
Gleich haben wir es.
Der Angriff B ist erfolgt.
Hä?
Okay, das war PPGuard ohne Ende.
Aber ich will den mit der Pistole bashen.
Ah, ich wusste es, dass wir dich mit der Pistole kriegen.
Die Pistole ist das Beste, was ihr im Nahkampf machen könnt.
Okay, oder mich vom Panzer wegschießen lassen.
Die Pistole ist so krass im Nahkampf im Burstmodus.
Das ist ein...
Das klatscht alles weg.
Kriegt man als Alpha-Tester auch was gezahlt von EA?
Ja, ich kriege was bezahlt wegen Sponsored-Videos.
Zum Glück.
Was?
Hä?
Was habe ich da gerade gesehen?
Okay.
Ich bin 29.
Gut, ich darf mich jetzt nicht beschweren.
Spiel das ja auch.
Die Chambre...
Ja, das war wirklich mal krasse Mario-Action.
Das ist ein Hovercraft.
Ein Hovercraft.
Nice.
Lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Ey, ich kriege gerade wirklich Anfälle.
Okay, okay.
Das ist eine gute Idee von dem Gegner.
Wir sind Erster.
Guck mal.
Assassin Squad.
Assassiniert.
Machen wir jetzt auch.
Weil ich habe da eigentlich ein ganz gutes...
Oh, Poggers, Poggers, Poggers.
Wo sind wir denn hier am Start?
Nice.
C1, C1.
Wir hatten Poggers am Start.
Oh, Poggers, Poggers, Poggers.
Wo sind wir denn hier am Start?
Nice.
C1, C1.
Wir hatten Poggers am Start.
Oh, Poggers, Poggers, Poggers.
Wo sind wir denn hier am Start?
Nice.
C1, C1.
Wir hatten Poggers am Start.
Hier.
Wir brauchen den kurzen Lauf.
Das da.
Und das.
Und wir haben Gachibust vom Hovercraft.
Ne, Terminated.
Von was genau wurde ich überhaupt jetzt getötet?
SBMM kickt rein.
Leute, ich habe echt die Vermutung, jetzt ohne Scheiß, das sind keine Ultra-Noobs,
die vor zwei Tagen angefangen haben hier.
Auf der anderen Seite sind 128 Spieler, die schießen einfach grob in die Richtung und
passt schon.
Guck mal.
Webster ist so geil, ne?
Aber du, du, das bringt halt gar nichts, dass ich jetzt hier gecrappelt habe.
Captain Poggers, ich hole dich.
Oh, nicht schlimm.
Lasst mich in Ruhe, Leute.
Bam.
Sehr schön.
Jawoll.
Nice.
Habe ich da hinter uns was gesehen gerade?
Ja.
Da ist er.
Vielleicht sehe ich von hier was.
Vielleicht kann ich den bashen hier.
Hier ist gar nichts.
Wo ist er?
Ich dachte, hier ist einer.
Nope.
Nicht da.
Hier.
Da hinten.
Guck mal.
Da.
Hier ist...
Ach, der ist auf dem Kran.
Der schleibert uns jetzt gleich.
Äh, habt ihr gesehen?
Der Midipack...
Midi-Stick hat nicht funktioniert.
Okay.
Oh.
Mann!
Die kommen hier gerade.
Die bashen mich.
Die Gachi basen mich weg.
Und mein scheiß Crappling-Hook funktioniert nicht.
Ich spiele jetzt was anderes.
Der war am Anfang...
Den haben die irgendwie kaputt gepatcht.
Der hat früher besser...
Also, was früher?
Der hat noch am Anfang der Woche besser funktioniert.
Ich meine, das kann doch nicht sein, dass es dann...
Das...
Ich kann nicht mehr rennen, mein Sprint ist kaputt.
Bedros, ich hole dich.
Komm, das kriegen wir jetzt, C2 holen wir noch.
Massive.
So, nochmal hier, Motion Sensor in die Ecke, weil hier steht einer, habe ich zumindest
gedacht.
Ich checke nicht wo, aber Motion Sensor, ach da ist, da ist so ein komisches Sentry-Ding.
Nice.
Fuck.
Okay.
Ich checke wirklich wo hier was abgeht, aber wir scheinen ja vorwärts zu kommen, wir scheinen
ja vorwärts zu kommen.
Das ist ja das Wichtige.
Pin, Pin, Corona-Booster-Impfung.
Alter, ey, ich kriege gerade wirklich Anfälle, es funktioniert ja nichts.
Ich bin gestartet, drücke S, aber nein.
Wallbang.
Bam, streckt.
Jetzt müssen wir hier hin.
Jetzt müssen wir hier, da, da steht, da stehen, ich weiß nicht von wo, ich habe keine Ahnung
von wo.
Ach, das ist so ein fucking Ranger, Monkaz, Monkaz, richtiger Monkaz-Moment hier.
Bisschen Headglitchen, bisschen Headglitchen geht immer.
Einfach mal richtig, richtig nice einen Headglitch machen.
Ein nicer Headglitch.
Gut gehettglitched.
Ja.
Gut gehettglitched ist halb gewonnen, das kennt man doch aus anderen Games.
Oder der Heli, oder der Heli bummst einen weg.
Macht der Ranger eigentlich auch irgendwas?
Ja, der schießt über 300 Meter einen an und finisht einen, wenn man Pech hat.
Ich, ganz ehrlich Leute, obwohl ich mich aufrege, wir sind, nein, wir sind eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich meine, wir sind immer vorne.
Wir machen immer ganz gut Kills.
Und das ohne Ranger.
Und das ohne Ranger, Heli oder sonstigen Müll.
Wir spielen einfach ganz normal Infanterie, das Game.
Okay, ich checke null, was abgeht, aber okay, wir gehen, wir gehen mal zurück.
Wir gehen mal weg.
Vielleicht, vielleicht kommen wir hier nämlich durch.
Jetzt bräuchte ich doch wieder Webster.
Jawoll.
Hat die gerade gesagt, fucker got eliminated?
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ich bin offended.
Ich bin höchst offended.
Wie kann man denn solche Language, Alter, verwenden hier?
Also.
Horstmann.
Ach, da war er.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen.
Triggert.
Ja, richtig triggert.
Lass mich auch mal triggert sein.
Das ganze Game ist, das ganze Game triggert mich permanent.
Habe ich euch eigentlich erzählt, für alle, die heute nicht dabei waren, heute morgen,
dass das Twitch meine, mein Wort gemutet hat?
Weil ich Hanzo, Hanzo Scatter nachgemacht habe und die haben gedacht, er sagt Scat.
Das ist ja sowas wie Scheiße oder so.
Das muss man natürlich muten.
Das ist, das geht nicht.
Kann.
Okay, Sundance sagt mal richtig hier.
Ich muss jetzt Webster auspacken.
Ich wollte gerade aus irgendwelchen Gründen sagen McCree, aber das war ein anderes Game.
Okay, gut.
Einmal eine
Monka, Monka, Monka, Monka.
Bester.
Bester Flyer.
Der musste sein.
Okay, es hat keinen Sinn.
Ich muss.
Ich muss was.
Ich weiß, dass McCree nicht McCree heißt mehr.
Ich muss was anderes spielen.
Mit Sundance kommst du hier nicht rauf.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht.
Nein.
Geht auch nicht.
Launchen hiervon.
O.K.
Einmal.
Warum...
Tango ist down.
Tango Sucker.
Der übrigens gar nicht Tango Sucker sagt.
Ja, nice. Sturmgewehr.
Beste.
Ja, klar.
Ey, die Sturmgewehre
sind so lächerlich.
Ich dachte aber früher in MW2...
Wer dachte noch, dass die Typen
in MW2 Tango Sucker sagen?
Also Sucker.
Machen sie gar nicht.
Okay, ich nehme
wieder den mit dem Crumpling Hook.
Der sagt irgendwas
Arabisches. Tango Sucker oder
sowas. Hört sich eh...
Sucker oder so. Frag mich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Oh nein, ich hab released. Sorry.
Irgendwas auf Arabisch
sagen die in MW2.
Es hört sich halt an wie Tango Sucker.
Guck mal, ein Hovercraft.
Das gab es ja schon lange nicht mehr.
Aliens vs. Hovercraft.
Kommt demnächst, hab ich gehört.
Oh.
Game.
Man funktioniert doch einfach.
Painstamp.
Ja, ich geb zu.
War schon sehr Painstamp-ig der Witz gerade.
Okay, jetzt ist nichts mehr da.
Da ist ein Sniper-Dude übrigens.
Guckt euch mal an.
So sieht es aus, wenn ein Game erlaubt
Self-Heal und Ammo-Boxen
auf dem kleinen Platz.
Einen gleichen Charakter zu haben.
One-Hit-Sniper,
Ammo-Boxen und Self-Heal auf dem gleichen
Charakter. Das ist eine
sehr, sehr gute Idee.
Dass man sich an den Rand der Map campen kann.
Und, tja,
was weiß ich, was der da macht, während er spielt.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, können wir
es jetzt einnehmen?
Wie ich mittlerweile...
Also ohne Scheiß, ich glaube...
Also heute spiele ich das noch
bis 23 oder so.
Wir gucken auch gleich mal die Reaction-Videos
noch. Ich glaube, ich habe
ohne Scheiß, ich habe kein
Battlefield
von den Mechanics und vom Gameplay
mehr gehasst als
dieses Spiel. Es ist einfach
nur schlecht.
Du kannst es auch null kontrollieren.
Haha, G-Baited.
Du kannst es einfach null kontrollieren. Du wirst immer
von der Seite irgendwie reingekla...
Kriegst du einen drauf.
Das ist jetzt so ein
besserer Modus. Ja, das stimmt.
Allerdings finde ich Hazard Zone auch nicht
irgendwie spielenswert.
Aktuell.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch die...
Hat der gerade
doppelt? Hat der gerade doppelt
Grappling-Hook? Gibt es da einen Bug, den ich noch
nicht kenne?
Ah, guck mal, der Vetris weiß Bescheid.
Grapple in place.
Ist schlecht, wenn das in place
wäre.
Schlechter als die Battlefield 3 Alpha. Ja, aber deutlich.
Die Battlefield 3 Alpha war richtig...
Oh, fuck. Richtig nice.
Also, ich glaube, länger als die Woche
spielt... Das ist der letzte Tag im Endeffekt,
wo ich das Game spiele.
Das ist jetzt durch. Ich meine,
ich bin... Ich habe fast alles unlockt.
Ich habe alles gesehen, soweit
ich es sehen will.
Und
ab jetzt ist es nur noch Pain.
Pains Champ.
Und Aufregen. Und das muss nicht sein.
Dann spiele ich lieber ein bisschen Halo
oder... Ich wollte ja auch schon unbedingt
mit das neue Age of Empires spielen.
Also die Kampagne. Multiplayer bin ich zu schlecht.
Aber nicht im Stream oder so, ne?
Sag ich gleich.
Ich wollte mein Zoo weiterbauen.
Ich habe genug Sachen zum Spielen aktuell.
Da ich mir den Kram
nicht mehr geben muss.
Assassin hat... Ach, wir sind nicht mehr Erster,
weil der Captain Poggers raus ist.
Du machst Pause. Ja, okay.
Ich finde aber... Guck mal.
Ich finde, die Punkte hätte man dem Squad ruhig lassen
können, wenn das einer left...
Also, wenn einer aus dem Squad
rausgeht.
Ich will da rein.
Lass mich rein. Lass mich rein.
Alter, lass mich rein.
Sind die... Sind die
alle so brain off card? Das ist ja keiner hier
vom Stream. Das ist ja irgendwie der random
Dude, der da mit rein ist.
Okay.
Das hier erinnert jetzt
ein bisschen an Damavand Peak. Und ihr werdet auch gleich
die Referenz sehen. Also hier gibt's
ja auch so... Also kann man auch so ein Basejump machen.
Dieser Basejump ist
aber nur drinne, um äh...
alte Fans
abzuholen, dass sie das Spiel pre-ordern.
Um sie dann heftig ausnehmen zu können.
Ach... Ach ja.
Dankeschön, Game.
Ich weiß nicht mal von wo. Ah, daneben.
Okay, gut.
Nein, nein.
Da ist ein Hovercraft, Mann. Und ein
Panzer. Ey, w...
Ist das so voll?
Was geht mit den Palmen ab? Das ist ein bisschen
wie aus... Die Witcher-Palmen.
Die... Die Witcher-Bäume.
Die haben sich ja auch so gebogen.
Ah, hier ist
Sturmgewehr.
Die Sturmgewehre. Die sind so schlecht, Mann.
Lohnt das Game?
Nein, auf keinen Fall.
Lohnt nicht.
Aktuell lohnt das nicht. Nein, nein.
Also, Leute.
Ich entschuldige mich jetzt schon mal bei euch.
Ich muss... Also für alle, die
das jetzt das letzte Mal so getriggert haben.
Ich muss morgen nochmal
ein sponsert Video hochladen.
Aber...
Erstens habe ich das vertraglich zugesichert.
Ist das eine Shotgun?
Oder was ist das? Leute, habt ihr einen Plan, was das hier ist?
Das ist eine Durch...
Eine Durchschieße-Shotgun.
Aber das muss sein.
Und dann habe ich wenigstens ein bisschen was verdient
an dem... An dem Game.
Oh, wir wurden Hackermanned.
Richtig. Hacker, Hacker, Hacker.
Oh, von hinten. Was kommt da von hinten?
Ah ja, obvius zu sehen.
Ja, ja, ja. Das läuft
nirgendwo flüssig. Ja, und ich habe auch
CPU-Drops auf Doom hier.
Die Einschläge von
diesem Ding lecken das Game übrigens.
Man kann nicht mehr weiterlaufen, wenn man gehittet wird.
Von dem...
Von dem 30mm-Geschütz.
Wie man gerade schön gesehen hat.
Könnte kurz einer aus dem Tank aus...
Ah, nice.
Sag mal, was hält denn das aus?
Okay, wie weit muss man hier
eigentlich genau vorhalten?
Lol.
Okay, ich verpiss mich.
Das soll
so sein.
Alles in dem Game soll so sein.
Mit Sicherheit.
Alles perfekt.
Ey, ich kann wieder nicht.
Ich kann nicht schießen. Ich kann nicht schießen.
Mein ADS und
meine linke Maustaste gehen gerade einfach nicht.
Ich kann...
Ich spiele einen Shooter, in dem ich nicht schießen kann, Mann.
Was zum Teufel
ist das? Was ist das
für eine Ausgeburt der Hölle, was ich hier spiele?
...
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Das ist doch wirklich nicht normal.
Hehe, Problem. Nein, alles gut.
Das ist kein Problem.
Get good reactions, Leute. Ihr habt es vorhin im Comment
gesehen. Man braucht einfach die
Reactions dafür. Ich habe einfach
nicht die Reactions gehabt.
Äh, normalerweise ist doch hier ein...
Ah, nee, hier ist es.
Ich kann da nicht runter, sorry.
Ist einfach mal implodiert
der Kopf von der...
Alter, was
ein Clusterfuck.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Man braucht einfach
mehr Reactions. Also, muss ja so...
Also, ich meine, ich glaube viel
besser als so 54-22
wird es eigentlich in dem Game
nicht. Und es macht halt trotzdem
keinen Bock. Deswegen. Ich sage es euch
wie es ist. Es ist wahrscheinlich heute der letzte Tag.
Battlefield 2042.
Ich habe alles gemacht,
was ich machen will. Game
fucked up. Also
spiele ich es nicht mehr. Fertig.
Bis bald das Game anfängt abzufucken
und ich da mehr rumrage
als Spaß dran zu haben, ist vorbei.
Ja, ey, klar, klar.
Ich hätte den gerade jetzt
tracken sollen beim
drüberspringen.
Der Chat, guck mal. Der Chat
ist auch wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig happy.
Wir haben verloren.
Bphands. Was hältst du denn von
Portal? Gibt es da große
Unterschiede zu den alten Teilen? Ja!
Riesenunterschiede.
Oh, cringe Gelaber. Mach weg.
Also eine Runde können wir, oder
1-2 Runden können wir noch spielen. Wie gesagt bis 23 Uhr.
Was wollte ich denn sagen?
Ja, ja. Also Battlefield 3
und Bad Company 2 in Portal haben
nichts mit dem Original zu tun.
Das einzige was da ist, sind halt
Maps aus dem jeweiligen, jeweils 2
Maps aus dem alten Teil drin. Aber
vom Gameplay, von den Mechanics,
vom Momentum,
von allem, spielt sich
das weder wie Battlefield 3, noch wie Bad Company 2.
Die Reactions haben
einfach gerade gefehlt. Ja, ist so.
Die Reactions haben gefehlt.
Zwei Major Patches.
Glaube ehrlich gesagt eher,
das Game, das braucht
Brage.
Die müssen ihre Erstgeborenen opfern
bei DICE, dass das noch was wird.
Anders kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
dass da noch was bei rumkommt.
So. Wir spielen jetzt
noch eine Runde.
Eine Runde spielen wir noch. Es sei denn,
es suckt. Dann Rage Quiddich. Und dann gucken
wir uns noch ein paar Battlefield
Sachen auf YouTube an, wie die Leute.
Also das Video vom Lost wollte ich mir auf jeden Fall angucken.
Der ähm
kotzt sich ja auch ein bisschen drüber aus.
Gucken wir mal.
Und ich will wissen, was er zu meinem Video gesagt hat.
Es hat mich einer angeschrieben und hat gemeint, hier guck mal,
er sagt was zu deinem Video. Bin mal gespannt,
was er zu meinem Video sagt, aber
weiß jemand, wann er was zu meinem Video sagt?
Also ich hab ab und zu
bei ihm schon reingeguckt. Ich glaub, das ist ein sehr
wie soll ich sagen, fähiger
äh Battlefield, nee wieso, wie soll ich das ausdrücken, also
also ich glaub dem,
wenn der sagt, dass er das Spiel
gut findet, dass es nicht rein aus Fanboy
ist. Ich glaube, der mag das Spiel wirklich.
Oh ne, Breakthrough
Orbital. Das heißt, ähm
ich lass da jedem seine Meinung. Deswegen
interessiert mich einfach nur, was er zu dem Video gesagt hat.
So
in der Mitte. Ja, super.
Reagier doch mal auf
das Video vom Subreddit. Du meinst,
dass ähm
Peter das Video? Oder welches?
Der sagt auch, Leute, ich sag's euch, das
P-P-Pega 29, wir haben's etabliert.
Das hat sich durchgesetzt.
Mach's gut, Moritz.
Also das kann sein, dass
ich's Rage quitte.
Weil
das hier wird nie eingenommen.
Und wir sind Attacker.
Na, das wird witzig.
Hast du schon das mit der Level 60?
Sniper gesehen? Ähm
du meinst die One-Head-Sniper oder was?
Oder, oder, also die
oder wie?
Oder die Sniper, wo man theoretisch
Fahrzeuge mit
beschädigen können sollte? Oder was meinst du?
Strike fast
in a hard Hyper-Gachi.
Ja, Chat, so sieht's aus.
Oh, guck mal, die Rakete. Die hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Schön, dass ihr mir das Intro zeigt.
Macht brutalen Vehicle-Damage.
Moin, Powerlocke.
Jawoll.
Jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's
rein, rein
geflogen hier.
Jetzt hätt ich das Spawn-Beacon mitnehmen sollen.
Wow.
Alter, der Dude will's wissen.
Nein. Game.
Game. Ja.
Warte, nein, ich hab das überhaupt nicht
gedrückt, Mensch.
Pain's Champ. Sehr gut.
Jetzt wisst ihr natürlich,
dass ich da bin. Was
ziemlich
sätge ist.
Sätge.
Sätge. Alter, wenn man das ein bisschen
kontrollieren kann, dann macht es ja direkt Bock.
Man kann, man kann es halt nicht
kontrollieren. Okay.
Nice. Erkennt man
die Bots? Ja, da steht AI davor.
Man erkennt die Bots. Bist du max FPS?
Korrekt.
Nein. Fake.
Lull.
Weggebumst.
Hahaha.
Ach, Moment, ich soll mal.
Guck mal, was haben wir denn da?
Ah, ein 30mm
Geschütz. Sehr gut.
Nee, ist ein 50mm
Geschütz, oder? Nee, 30.
Bam.
Schub, schub, schub, schub, schub.
Suche Gegner.
Oh.
Dozer. Oh.
Ich seh nix.
Eh, eh.
Siege.
Nice.
Würdest du das Game noch empfehlen? Nein.
Wie gesagt, ich empfehle das Game echt niemand
gerade.
Wirklich nicht. Beim besten Willen nicht.
Okay. Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Vielleicht haben wir Glück. Ich kann
hier hoch.
Irgendwie. Irgendwie.
Jawoll.
Massive. Realismus pur
jetzt. Geht's ab.
Massive Hyper Realism.
Passt wie ein Armer.
Was macht der da eigentlich?
Ey.
Ich bin so dumm.
Ich hab, ich hab den vergessen.
Ich hab den vergessen, den Dude.
Ich hab den nur noch unten gesehen.
Richtig dumm.
Lull.
Boomer.
Schon spät, Leute. Schon spät.
Vielleicht
jetzt ein Hovercraft oder so trocken.
Nein, ist nicht da.
Schon spät, ja. Ranger aber schnell.
Komm.
Ranger gib ihm.
Ranger stellts.
Lull.
Sturmgewehre. Lull.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Habt ihr gesehen, wie viele
Hits der braucht?
Sturmgewehre. Omega Lull.
Hyper Mega Lull.
Was Call of Duty hat
auch nichts gerissen dieses Jahr, kann ich
nicht beurteilen, Leute.
Keine Ahnung.
Wie ist Vanguard so?
Ich hab nicht vor, mir's zu kaufen, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber wie ist so?
Ich hab ganz unterschiedliche Sachen gehört.
Ich hab Leute gehört, die sagen, endlich mal wieder ein geiles Call of Duty seit Jahren.
Ich habe auch
genug Leute gehört, die gesagt haben,
Sucked.
You're moving off the map.
Ja, sehr realistischer Funkspruch.
Ich dachte, renn mal raus.
Richtiger Müll ist das?
Okay.
Hm.
Ich glaub's euch, Leute.
Ich glaub's euch sofort, dass das richtiger Müll ist.
Ist das der Shotgun?
Ey, das ist der Shotgun-Tank.
Oder ist das überhaupt eine Shotgun?
Hat irgendjemand einen Plan, was das hier ist?
Das ist eine Shotgun, oder?
So Kanister-Shell oder sowas.
Das macht aber kein Damage.
Das macht überhaupt kein Damage für eine Shotgun, Mann.
Das ist auch so ein undurchdachtes Ding.
Was genau soll
diese Waffe machen?
Was ist eigentlich deine Meinung
zu Battlefield 4, 1 und 5?
Ähm, Battlefield 4 find ich nice.
Hä?
Was ist das?
Das ist ja das most useless
Attachment, was ich
jemals an einem Tank gesehen hab.
Was ist das?
Damit kann ich meine Katze streicheln.
Ja.
Übrigens, könnt ihr euch dran erinnern?
Battlefield, äh, 1?
Ab wann ging das los?
Oder war das sogar schon in 4, wo man hier normal
hochklettern konnte an den Wänden?
Was man jetzt gestrichen hat?
Spiel.
Alter.
Das war Battlefield 1.
Aber in Battlefield 5 ging das auch, oder?
Grip.
Das ist eine Shotgun.
Ja, aber das ist eine Tank-Shotgun.
Kanister-Shell ging bisher immer über Range.
Okay, okay. Leute, vielleicht haben wir
Glück. Wir können jetzt MP9 spielen.
Vielleicht dürfen wir jetzt MP9 spielen.
Ich will endlich mal MP9 spielen, aber nein, ich darf keine MP9 spielen.
Weil PP gar 29 halt
Meta ist.
Ah, get fucked up in the ass over here.
Vielleicht kriege ich einen Rats.
Es wäre richtig massive,
wenn ich einen Rats kriege, weil ich meine, ich lick.
Nein.
Den hab ich weggesprayt.
Okay, ich würde sagen, es wird Zeit,
Leute. Es wird Zeit.
Wenn man gewinnen will,
muss man auch die passende Waffe, dann kann man
dafür spielen.
Das hier ist aber auch
schwer. Ich finde, das ist schon richtig schwer.
Und das hier ist unschaffbar im Attacker.
Okay, das war
PP-Guard. Gebe ich zu.
Aber vielleicht kriege ich einen Rats. Es wäre sehr schön.
Sehr schön, Leute, wenn ihr mich ratzen würdet.
Oh, solid Snack.
Nice.
Solid reingesnackt.
Richtig solide hier.
Richtig solide.
Äh.
Ich muss wieder weg.
Ja, vielleicht stellst du
wir uns am Rand der Map rum und dann klappt es irgendwie.
Mal hier so.
Hier so vielleicht.
Ja, das ist so.
Es ist so gute Deckung.
Es ist so gute Deckung hier.
Da möchte man,
da möchte man einfach eine ganze Weile sitzen
und hier
eine Runde, eine Runde
pepo-comfy machen.
Also die Deckungen sind schon richtig, richtig
gut.
Tja.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Ich höre, hier unten ist doch noch was,
Mann, oder?
Ich habe hier was gehört noch.
Oh, da ist noch mehr.
Wusste ich doch.
Da kommen noch mehr jetzt.
Haben wir es jetzt?
Oh, der fuckt
sich jetzt ab, ey.
Reingeflogen.
Voll ins Gesicht aus dem
Flug, Mann.
Damit hat er
nicht gerechnet.
Es wäre ja schon geholfen, wenn man nicht hier lang rennen
müsste, sondern, sondern hier lang
laufen dürfte.
Weißt du was?
Ich gehe da jetzt rein und fuck den Typ ab.
So.
Ist mir egal, ob ich sterbe. Ich fuck jetzt den Typ hier noch
ab.
So, easy. Jetzt kann ich sterben.
Dead girl.
Das hat sich gelohnt.
Rest ist mir egal.
Kommst eh nicht runter.
Oh, wir haben Hovercraft an A.
Oh, das ist Hovercraft.
Noch eins, noch eins.
Nein, nein, nein.
Toxic.
Warum ist das toxic?
Also, wenn was toxic ist, dann das
Map-Design, oder?
Nice, was muss ich für ein
Shoutout in deinen nächsten Videos?
Tier 3 Sub, Kappa.
Selbst Tier 3 Sub.
Also, Shoutouts ist ja quasi
Werbung.
Und da musst du mir quasi das bieten,
was mir EA geboten hat,
dass ich dieses Spiel bewerbe.
Und du kannst dir vorstellen, das war nicht billig.
Wobei doch,
das war billiger, als es hätte sein gemusst,
weil ich dachte zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt ja noch,
das Spiel wird gut. Max, ich hole dich.
Ach komm, wir haben gutes Wetter.
Oh, PP-Guard. Richtig, PP-Guard.
Ich geb mir auch überhaupt keine Mühe
mehr gerade.
Da kannst du nicht mitteilen. Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Richtig
wer PP-Guard.
Stay back!
Und nach der
Runde ist Schluss, da gucken wir noch ein bisschen Kram.
Zu dem Game.
Und wie sich die anderen
Leute aufregen. Eigentlich wollte ich zurück, weil da oben
war noch was gerade.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich zurück gehe,
werden wir sterben, weil es drüben keiner
Captured.
Ich muss zurück.
Ich muss zurück, da oben geht es ab.
Oh ja.
Der PP-Guard ist rein.
Da kommt was.
Da kommt ein
Hovercraft. Nee, Panzer.
Panzer.
Pantsman.
Der Pantsman ist am Start.
Ah, nice.
Schön. Schön, dass
ich von irgendwo sonst wo...
Nein, du hast mich doch nicht gesehen, Mann.
Overtime. Ja, sehr gut.
Overtime.
Overtime, beste.
Alles Overtime.
Overtime, gib mir.
Overtime.
Ich flieg da jetzt rein und Capture, Leute.
Jetzt. Jetzt.
Achtung.
Nein, ich darf nicht mal starten. Alles klar.
Na gut. Max spielt Fifa. Nein, ich
spiele kein Fifa. Wie kommt es darauf, dass ich Fifa spiele?
Hä?
Wie kommt... Oh, nee. Ich habe es wieder nicht
mitgekriegt.
Oh, nice. Nice. Nice.
Oh, lass mich rein.
Lass mich rein, Gachi Bass. Lass mich rein.
Jetzt wird gecaptured, Mann.
Massive huge
Capture.
Wir kriegen es. Ich fasse es nicht.
Leute, wir kriegen es.
Aber wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste ist?
Die nächste Base
ist nicht...
ist nicht einnehmbar.
Oh, von hinten kommt was.
Gachi Bass. Der will in meinen Bobbes.
So. Weiter.
Nächste. Wo ist er?
Okay, jetzt kriege ich es jetzt.
Jetzt kriege ich es.
Jetzt kriege ich es gut ab.
Haben wir es?
Okay, jetzt müssen wir schnell sein. Wir müssen...
Wir haben einen Angriff. Wir haben eine
Möglichkeit, den Kram einzunehmen.
Man darf nicht... Also...
Scheiß auf das Unten.
Man muss mit allen Mann direkt aufs Dach,
bevor die Typen auf dem Dach
alle hoch sind und gespawnt sind.
Wenn die schlau sind, spawnen die halt
alle oben schon direkt. Aber
man hat einen Angriff,
um das hinzubekommen.
Einen Attack hat man.
Aber es ist einfach durchgeflogen
gerade wieder.
Einen Attack haben wir.
Hallo. Wingsuit.
Wenn du gewinnst, sage ich, das kannst du nicht gewinnen.
Das geht nicht. Das ist eigentlich
not winnable.
Not stonks
sozusagen.
Vielleicht hat der Lost das schon mal
verloren, glaube ich nicht.
Und außerdem, da lag es bestimmt nicht an ihm.
Wie, warum?
Weil der Lost ziemlich gut in Battlefied ist.
Und wenn die die Runde verlieren, liegt das
wahrscheinlich nicht an ihm.
Oh, das sind zu viele, Mann.
Das wäre so ein Gachi-Buzz gewesen.
Aber
von der Seite weggeklatscht.
Das wäre
der krasseste Gachi-Buzz aller Zeiten gewesen.
In dem Spiel.
Aber gibt es nicht.
Äh.
Ja gut, dann warte ich jetzt, bis wir B2 gecaptured haben,
dass ich unten spawnen kann.
Ich warte jetzt, bis er eingenommen ist.
Hoffentlich, hoffentlich wird er eingenommen.
Und dann spielen wir
schöne MP9.
Ne, die Granaten sind zu gut.
Jetzt ist es eh vorbei, also
wir hätten eine Chance gehabt,
das einzunehmen.
Der lebt noch.
Glaube ich zumindest. Ich glaube, der lebt noch, der Dude da hinten.
Mann!
Fuck!
Okay, das hat er wenigstens
geschickt gemacht. Da kann ich mich jetzt nicht
über das Game aufregen.
Nice. Reds. Reds. Reds.
Reds. Reds.
Reds.
Reds. Pog.
Tick-Tick-Quick.
Tick-Quick.
Danke für den Bits.
Fünf Spilianen. Ich sehe es jetzt nicht genau.
Gutes Riffy. Ja. Nice.
Schön, wenn es dir gefallen hat.
Achtung.
Big Brain-Aid.
Guck mal, und hat gehittert.
Big Brain-Aid. Wieder. Nein.
Small Brain.
Not Big Brain.
Alter, ist ja gut, Mann.
Okay.
Da wäre ich auch beim Daily
Scrum von DICE gerne dabei gewesen.
Wer sich
hier überlegt hat,
dass das eine gute Idee ist.
Oh, wir haben sogar was gekillt.
Ja, sehr gute Idee. Sehr gute Idee.
Das geht jetzt hoch, aber...
Guck mal. Ich meine,
ich mache wahrscheinlich mehr...
mehr Damage und mehr Kills, wenn ich einfach
hier unten stehe und spamme Granaten rein.
Hä?
Wo kommt denn der jetzt her?
Oh, guck mal. Nice. Jetzt habe ich auf.
Jetzt habe ich Release. Das war dumm.
Push. Push. Push. Noobs in Backside.
Alles klar.
Nee. Das hat mit Noobs nichts zu tun.
Das ist einfach nicht einnehmbar.
Achtung.
Check.
Es ist übrigens auch ganz wichtig,
dass bei so einem fucking OP-Spot
die Defender auch noch
einen Heli haben.
Scheint mir
ganz wichtig für die Balance zu sein.
Warum man nicht einnehmen kann?
Naja, weil das zu klein ist.
Also, wo man hochkommt.
Das geht nicht.
Not enough space to deploy? Warum?
Ah, habt ihr gesehen, wie schnell
die Leute weg waren?
Die aimen halt einfach alles ab.
Und du kannst halt auch easy alles abamen.
Das ist einfach nur
richtig maximal dumm.
Was man sich
dabei gedacht hat, Alter. Das ist so...
Das ist unglaublich dumm
und hängen geblieben, ja.
Was anderes fällt mir echt nicht mehr ein.
Ja.
Klar.
Klar. Klar.
Natürlich.
Da war es einfacher, Metro einzunehmen.
Ja, Metro konnte man ja noch irgendwie einnehmen.
Ich müsste fließen
zwischen Webster und der hier wechseln können,
dass du irgendwie eine Chance hast,
halbwegs da irgendwo sinnvoll hinzukommen.
Ein Problem, PP29.
Das ist richtig.
Hast du Probleme, nimm einfach die PP29.
Dann hast du keine Probleme mehr.
Alles.
Okay. YOLO. YOLO.
Die aimen schon ab. Ich sag euch.
Ich predikte, Leute. Die aimen mich schon ab,
bevor ich richtig oben bin.
Links. Rechts. Links. Rechts.
Ich geh links. Ich geh links. Ich geh links.
Guck hier. Die aimen mich schon ab.
Und tschüss.
Und wieder hoch.
Und rechts. Und rechts. Und rechts.
Und rechts.
Ey, du!
Also, was anderes fällt mir gar nicht ein.
Wir machen mal den Winx und wir dazu einfach C drücken.
Oder E? E oder C?
Ich mach das schon automatisch. Ich glaub C.
Richtig gutes Design.
Sehr gut.
Das ganze Team müsste von allen Seiten kommen.
Dann geht das.
Also, ich will nicht bestreiten, dass wenn man
es wirklich auf die Sekunde genau koordiniert
und ein richtig gutes Team hat gegen
vielleicht nicht ganz so gute Gegner,
dass es vielleicht funktioniert.
Übrigens, Kommentare in meinem Video
erklären, wie das einfach geht.
Ich hab einen Comment gelesen,
der erklärt,
wie man Orbital,
dieses B1 auf dem Haufen,
wie man das ganz einfach einnimmt.
Einfach Luftunterstützung anfordern.
Einfach einen Heli anfordern,
der das Dach cleart.
Das steht genauso in den Kommentaren
unter meinem Video.
Einfach einen Heli anfordern, der das Dach cleart.
Sollte doch eigentlich
jedem einleuchten.
Just Heli anfordern
und das Dach clearen. Easy.
Kein Problem.
Mich interessiert, was der Lost dazu sagt.
Der hat sich ja ein bisschen bedeckt gehalten
in den letzten Tagen.
Ich würd mich echt mal interessieren, was er sagt.
Gucken wir uns das nochmal an.
Was sagt er denn?
Der Cluster.
ein. Du kannst ein Team machen aus
irgendwie den ultrakrassen Pros,
die reacten auch nicht
4 vs 128 alles
weg. Wie soll das überhaupt funktionieren,
wenn du die Gegner noch nicht immer siehst? Du kannst ja
schlecht auf was reagieren, was du nicht siehst.
Also hat er voll und ganz recht. Also die Leute, die das nicht
verstehen wollen, verstehe ich nicht.
Das war du einfach von der Masse an Leuten,
die vor dir stehen jetzt, die man teilweise
mal 2 nehmen kannst im Durchschnitt
im Vergleich zu den Teilen davor, weil es ja auch
die Top-Hit-Ansage an Spielern ist. Das heißt,
du musst nicht 2-3 Leute, die auf einmal vor dir
aufploppen versuchen zu killen, sondern es sind
5 plus, die dich am Schluss
töten, auch wenn du 3 wegbekommst, weil der Rest,
wenn er nicht gerade PP-geistig herkillen kann,
oder die Leute, die mit der Sniper
reinamen, mit der DMR
reinamen oder von der Seite gerade reinspornen
oder reinlaufen, die dich halt dann killen.
So ist es.
So blöd sich's anhört, für den guten Spieler
irgendwann ein bisschen frustrierend, weil er merkt, dass er
selbst mit seinen Fähigkeiten nicht dagegen ankommt.
Was noch ein Punkt ist, der dazu...
Und es ist ja auch nicht so, als könntest du sagen,
ich übe
das jetzt richtig krass. Da gibt's
eigentlich nix zu üben.
Emily, Smile, Zorras, danke
ihr beiden für den Sub.
...der dafür spricht, und jetzt komme ich auf den Punkt,
um was es geht, dass, in Anführungsstrichen,
schlechtere Spieler belohnt werden.
Das ist momentan so. In Battlefield 2042
ist es so und aktuell
so oft... Aber ich finde,
das war zu einem Teil,
in Call of Duty eh schon eine ganze Weile so,
und
das war in Battlefield auch so, aber
nicht so extrem.
...aufgebaut, ob es so gewollt ist,
kann man jetzt nur vermuten, aber ist Battlefield 2042
so aufgebaut, dass, dass
obvious, schlechtere Spieler belohnt werden.
Ein weiterer Faktor dafür ist nämlich der Bloom.
Das heißt, die Tatsache, dass ja momentan
Sachen wie unter anderem Assault Rifles auf eine
gewisse Entfernung so eine krasse Streuung haben,
dass die halt nicht auf den Punkt gehen,
dass es jetzt einfach so...
Ja gut, ähm, Chat, klar, die sind auch frustriert,
wenn sie keinen Fuß auf den Boden kriegen, aber die haben
andere Ansprüche. Die haben die Ansprüche
mal, ähm,
zehn Minuten in Richtung der Gegner
zu sprayen und dann halt zwei Kills zu machen.
Dann sind die happy. Ich hatte auf der Arbeit,
jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt Boomer Story, aber ist noch nicht so lange her,
ich hatte vor bis ungefähr einem Jahr
ein, ein, der ist noch ein bisschen älter,
wahrscheinlich würde ich sagen so 40 ein Kollege auf der Arbeit,
der hat Fortnite gespielt.
Der hat einen Sohn, der hat Fortnite gespielt und der Vater
hat dann auch Fortnite gespielt, so.
Und da war das noch neu, also schon zwei Jahre
oder drei Jahre her, da war das noch relativ neu
und er hat nie gewonnen.
Und hatte, hatte trotzdem ultra Spaß an diesem
Game, weil der immer eins,
zwei Leute gekillt hat. Und irgendwann ist
der morgens, meinst du, kein Scheiß,
der ist morgens zu mir gekommen, halt Max, ich muss dir was
erzählen. Ich hab gestern eine Runde
Fortnite gewonnen. Ich lag, und
das ist jetzt kein Witz, der hat gesagt, er hat erzählt,
ich lag einfach rum und die anderen haben
sich beschossen und am Ende war ich der
Letzte, der übrig war. Der hat nichts
gemacht, der hat einfach nur in der Ecke gelegen und hat gewonnen.
Und hat sich das Todes
gefreut, der war mega happy.
Also da sieht man, die Ansprüche
von so den ultra casual Spielern
sind auch viel niedriger.
Und dementsprechend muss das
Game sowas einbauen, dass die
einfach mal random
Mice in die Gegner sprayen können
und einmal einen Kill kriegen. Dann ist
für den die Woche gerettet. Der lockt sich
abends ein, spielt eine halbe Stunde
und davon macht der,
und davon macht der eine Viertelstunde
PPGA 29
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam
Dauerfeuer
in die Gegner und dann macht er zwei
Kills und dann legt er sich abends hin und
denkt sich,
ha,
das war mal richtig schön und haben mal richtig
schöne Runde gezockt. So war
das geil. Und dann pennt er und ist happy.
So. Dafür ist das gemacht.
Moku-chan, dankeschön.
Ich weiß, dass ich nicht ultra beschissen spiele.
Ich weiß auch, dass ich jetzt nicht super krass spiele oder so.
Es ist, also es ist
durchaus in Ordnung, finde ich.
Mit der MP, die ist schon ein bisschen genauer.
Vor allem die Pega 29.
Deswegen spielt die auch gerade wieder.
Jetzt fängt er auch schon an.
Jetzt fängt er auch schon an. Leute, ich habe echt,
ich glaube echt, wir haben das etabliert
hier. Ich habe das in meinem
Video gesagt vor zwei Tagen. Da hat es noch niemand
benutzt. Und hier im Chat auch. Und jetzt fangen
sie alle an.
Zu geil.
Das findest du geil.
Alle.
Pega 29.
Ja.
Recall Control oder was auch immer.
Das Wichtigste, ich sag euch jetzt mal, was für mich
in Battlefield das mit Abstand Wichtigste ist,
um gut zu spielen.
Das ist auch ein bisschen spielertypabhängig.
Okay. Das Wichtigste ist Position
in Battlefield für mich.
Wenn du mit Hirn spielst
und
die Gegner outmovst,
musst du sie nicht outaimen.
Ich kann sicherlich
so die richtig krassen jungen
Flick-Twitch-Aimer
nicht mehr outaimen.
Aber ich kann mit Hirn spielen
und, sag man mal, 90% der Gegner
outplayen.
Und das funktioniert nicht mit 128
Spieler und dem Randomness, wie dieses Game hat.
Das ist
mein eigentliches Problem.
Du hast eine gute Idee,
gut ausgeführt, wirst aber
richtig weggefickt
von der Seite. Für was du
nichts kannst. Weil du kannst einfach
nicht ohne Information
predikten, wo der jetzt ist.
Man muss immer dazu sagen, es wird
uns immer erzählt,
dass das in Battlefield-Teilen davor auch der Fall war.
Unter anderem, weil viele Leute
im Portal das zum Beispiel mit Battlefield
Bad Company verglichen haben.
Und dann gesagt wurde, dass Battlefield Bad Company teilweise
auch so eine Streuung hat.
Ja, ja, die Leute sind blöd. Also ganz ehrlich, wer in Portal
geht, Bad Company 2 anschmeißt,
sieht, dass die Waffen streuen und darauf schließt,
dass Bad Company 2 ernsthaft
auch so eine Streuung gehabt hat. Die sind einfach
ja, was anderes, was anderes,
das ist einfach
hängen geblieben.
Das Schwachste,
Bad Company 2 hatte nie
im Leben so eine Streuung. Bad Company 2
hat dich belohnt, wenn du Singleschuss machst.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber du musstest so, auch mit der
SOR musstest du quasi, in Bad Company 2
hast du mit der SOR so
geschossen. Guck, mit der
SOR hast du so geschossen. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das jetzt irgendwie
zeigen kann. Mit der SOR hast du so
geschossen. Also
hast du immer so runtergezogen
dabei. So, und bist permanent auf
dem Gegner dadurch geblieben.
So, und
das ist hier nicht möglich
in dem Game.
Ups, warum
habe ich hier...
Oh, den hat er nice gebasht.
... natürlich sagen können, nee, stimmt nicht.
Die Ungenauigkeit der Waffen ist im Original Bad Company
zum Beispiel nicht...
Nicht so. Nö, nö.
... wie es aktuell in Bad Company Waffen im Portal
oder so ist. Und wir haben das alles...
Gar nicht.
... brauchst gefühlt zwei Magazine, wenn du auf
einen Typen reinschießt. Selbst wenn du einen Burst machst
und Co. Und das sind
alles Sachen, die dafür sprechen, dass die schlechteren
Spieler, und das ist gar nicht böse gemeint, ne?
Es ist jetzt gar kein Rant...
Naja, ein bisschen schon.
... aber ich gebe ihm ja recht.
Das ist halt, entweder ist es marketingtechnisch
extra so gedacht...
Ist es.
... um halt auch den...
Habe ich auch schon oft gesagt, 128 Spieler ist
hauptsächlich Marketinggeschiss gewesen.
... alle Casual-Spieler anzusprechen,
wie vielleicht auch nur die 20 Jahre Liga.
Das ist, um zu sagen, größer, besser,
latest, greatest Battlefield,
dafür ist es gedacht. Spielerisch hat es...
Spieler haben sich gedacht, ich spiele mal ein Battlefield,
weil, hey, krass, ich kann jetzt Kills machen, holy shit, also.
Da kann man nur vermuten, das kann man jetzt nur...
Das kann man nur in Frage stellen.
Aber Fakt ist, dass diese Mechaniken
aktuell dazu führen, dass es so ist.
Und das ist für einen Spieler, der halt
länger Shooter schon spielt...
Okay, ich muss zugeben, dass jetzt...
Ich gebe ihm recht, man hätte das aber besser
verargumentieren können. Ich meine zu sagen,
es ist so, es ist Fakt, dass es so
ist, ist vielleicht nicht die beste Begründung.
Aber es ist so.
Der Bad Company 2, also
das hat im Leben nicht diese Streuung
gehabt, wie es hier in Portal hat.
Übelst frustrierend. Hier ist übrigens der Cluster,
gegen den du in dem Moment nichts machen kannst.
Deine Fähigkeiten limitiert werden durch Einstellungen,
die das Spiel hat. Das Spiel sagt einfach nein.
Das ist halt der Punkt. Da muss auf jeden Fall was passieren.
Ach, übrigens, das mit diesen 128 Spieler,
das wird ja auch gerne als Ausrede
verwendet. Ja, das Spiel ist technisch so
krass und hat 128 Spieler. Es gibt
einen Mod für Battlefield 3.
Wenn du da einen fetten Server hattest, mit fetter
Single-Core-CPU, konntest du auch 127
Spieler spielen. Und das lief.
Und das war nicht hier
Slow-Motion.
Also wenn, also
das ist jetzt nicht hier Raketentechnologie
mit 128 Spieler.
Klar, die Interaktion
ist in diesem Spiel ein bisschen größer,
aber das ist wie gesagt jetzt kein Teufelszeug
oder so.
... die jetzt schon zumindest über Twitter
gesagt, dass die Sachen auf dem Schirm
haben und anpassen werden. Aber man muss auf jeden Fall
aufpassen.
Wir müssen als Spieler aufpassen,
dass wir uns natürlich nicht mit diversen Sachen
abspeisen lassen, right?
Ich bin jemand, der sagt, in jedem
Shooter gehören für mich Recall-Patterns
rein. Das heißt, dass du...
Das...
Das finde ich nicht.
Das muss nicht sein.
Es würde ja schon reichen, wenn
das Waffenhandling halbwegs normal ist.
... festgelegte Movements hast,
je nachdem, welche Waffe du spielst. Das braucht man nicht unbedingt.
Wenn du einfach hin an die Wand drückst,
kann man sich drüber streiten.
Wir kennen das aus Good Old Counter-Strike, wo du ein umgedrehtes
L schießen musst bei der M4 oder so, um am Schluss
halt im Spray, wir reden von
Sprayen, halt relativ punktgenau
in Anführungsstrichen schießen zu können.
Natürlich ist immer ein gewisser Spread, aber der ist halt
dann nicht so, sondern der ist
halt dann auf einem Punkt, right?
Alles klar. Ich bin jemand, der das seit
Jahren erzählt, warum Shooter nicht einfach
festgelegte Recall-Patterns reinmachen,
weil dann ist es nämlich gleiches Recht
für alle. Jeder hat die Möglichkeit,
abhängig davon natürlich, wie viel Zeit...
Gleiches Recht für alle darf doch nicht sein,
wie sollen die das Game dann verkaufen?
Aber jeder hat die Möglichkeit, sich eine Waffe
auszusuchen, zu sagen, hey, die mag ich,
und die zu trainieren und zu lernen.
Weil jeder hat am Schluss die gleichen
Voraussetzungen.
Ja, das stimmt schon,
aber das geht auch ohne
Recall-Pattern. Also ich bin
eigentlich nicht so der Freund von
100% Recall.
Ich finde, das Handling der
Waffe sollte eben anständig sein,
man sollte nicht krass einen zusätzlichen
Random-Faktor machen, sodass es ab dem 5.
Schuss gar nichts mehr trifft.
Aber ich finde,
so die richtig 100% Recall-Pattern,
wie beispielsweise in CS,
das brauchst du eigentlich nicht.
Es wird ja schon reichen, wenn man es
nicht noch schlimmer macht.
Du hast eine Waffe, wenn du die sprayen willst
auf die Entfernung, was meistens in Shootern
der Fall ist, gerade mit Assault-Rifles
oder so, außer du schießt halt über 200 Meter
und dann musst du halt Einzelfeuer machen
oder einfach einen Sniper nehmen, dass du halt,
um das zu erreichen und nicht pepegamäßig
komplett die Tauben rum wegzuschießen,
oder irgendwo hinzusprayen, musst du die Waffe
halt lernen. Und das kostet halt Zeit,
aber das bietet ja auch einen langfristigen
Spielspaß, weil du merkst, wie besser du wirst,
wie du besser bist mit der Waffe.
Und das bietet halt einfach einen
Also ich finde, es hat schon gereicht, wenn es so ist
wie in Battlefield, sagen wir mal Battlefield 3,
da hast du sowas wie eine M16 oder eine AEK,
die AEK hat ja auch irgendwie den da gemacht,
da hast du halt ein bisschen dagegen gezogen,
die M4 hat einen großen Kick und ging dann eigentlich
mehr oder weniger Stride hoch und sowas.
Ich finde, das reicht, das muss
sich hundertprozentig irgendwie,
so mal genau sein, auf hundertprozentig
oder so. Also ordentliches,
ordentliches, ähm,
also es ist ja ein Unterschied zwischen Recoil-Pattern
und Recoil. Recoil ist ja quasi, wenn die Waffe
äh, hochzieht,
Recoil-Pattern ist,
dass es so ist wie in CS,
dass es nicht dorthin schießt,
wo du hinzielst,
es sei denn,
du zielst dorthin
mit dem Fadenkreuz,
wo du dann nicht hinschießt, weil du weißt,
das Recoil geht jetzt dahin.
Wisst ihr, wie ich mein? In CS ist es ja so,
wenn du in CS, sagen wir mal, mit der AK
spielst, dann
ist das Fadenkreuz
in der Mitte, aber du schießt,
aber du musst dann, du musst
es dann, irgendwie, wie
ging das CS nochmal, irgendwie so
runterziehen oder so?
Ähm, und dann irgendwie
hin und her, ne? Irgendwie so schräg
runter und dann hin und her mit der AK, ich krieg das immer,
ich krieg das immer hin. Aber,
du zielst dann nicht dorthin mit dem Fadenkreuz,
wo du wirklich hinschießt,
aber du weißt, wo der Recoil
hingeht. Das ist ja der Unterschied zwischen Recoil
und Recoil-Pattern. Moment,
ich zeige euch das.
CS, AK, Recoil
Pattern.
Du versteht nix, okay.
Spray-Pattern, okay.
Okay, Achtung.
Achtung.
Okay.
Okay, guckt es euch an.
Ihr seht,
das Fadenkreuz ist da,
die Schüsse gehen dahin.
So, das heißt,
was musst du jetzt machen,
wenn du willst, dass es in der Mitte steht,
du musst dein Fadenkreuz, also wenn du willst,
dass der Schuss hier bleibt,
musst du dein Fadenkreuz
dahin ziehen.
Guckt.
Der zeigt's gleich.
Äh, dahin.
Ne, dahin.
Der Mitte steht, ja.
Guckt, seht ihr?
Seht ihr?
Nein, nicht.
Er schießt dahin, sein Fadenkreuz ist da.
Nee, das Fadenkreuz soll sich nicht bewegen.
Du musst das Fadenkreuz bewegen,
aber du schießt halt nicht dorthin, wo das Fadenkreuz ist.
Recoil ist einfach nur,
ho, also ist einfach nur,
sag mal, bewegen des Fadenkreuzes nach oben mit A,
du, und du kannst runterziehen,
ähm, und du bist immer dort drauf,
wo dein Fadenkreuz ist.
In Battlefield bist du, schießt die Waffe,
außer, außer Random Faktor,
schießt die, in Battlefield schießt die Waffe,
und die Call of Duty auch,
schießt die Waffe dorthin, wo dein Fadenkreuz ist.
Das heißt, in Battlefield ziehst du einfach nur runter
und behältst das Fadenkreuz auf dem Target.
In CS ist das anders.
In CS ist dein Target hier,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das Fadenkreuz richtig kennt,
in CS ist dein Target hier,
und ihr seht doch, guckt mal, der schießt dahin,
guckt mal, wo der mit dem Fadenkreuz ist.
Der schießt hier hin,
und sein Fadenkreuz ist da unten.
Deswegen, ich finde, das muss in Battlefield nicht sein.
Das ist halt das, was du bei Recoil-Pattern hast.
Guck mal,
der schießt da unten hin,
das Fadenkreuz ist da,
und das ist halt das, was du bei Recoil-Pattern hast.
Und da schießt er hin.
Und in Battlefield ist es halt so,
du stayst auf Target,
geiler Satz, ich weiß,
und solltest dann dahin schießen,
solange du in der Lage bist, die Waffe runterzuziehen,
dass dein Ziel im Target bleibt.
Das ist halt der Unterschied.
Das ist nicht richtig scheiße,
das ist in CS 90,
das ist in CS mindestens die Hälfte des Skills,
des Spray- und Waffenhandling.
Umso höher man kommt, umso weniger.
Ich glaube, Lost möchte nicht, dass das so ist wie in CS.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, was er meint.
Dass es so ist wie in CS, glaube ich nicht.
Deswegen sage ich ja,
ich mag den Recoil, wie er in Battlefield 3, 4 und so ist,
aber ich will nicht Recoil-Patterns wie in CS haben.
... dranbleiben lässt.
Und das ist meines Erachtens für jedes Game da draußen nur positiv.
Klar wirst du ein paar Stimmen haben von den absoluten,
den absoluten Casual-Playern am unteren Ende,
so, und das ist wie gesagt nicht böse gemeint,
aber die sich halt denken,
naja, aber ich will jetzt keinen Effort reinlegen,
ich will einfach stupide ballern.
Ja gut, aber dann kann ich dir ja unter anderem ganz viele Shooter nennen,
die das mittlerweile ja anbieten, unter anderem, ja...
Ey, wie wär's mit Battlefield 5?
Battlefield 1?
Ich meine, du konntest in allen Battlefields stupide ballern.
Äh, hier jetzt halt noch etwas stupider,
nur mit noch weniger, äh, ja, Nachvollziehbarkeit dahinter, leider.
Es ist nicht so, als gäbe es da keine Shooter,
aber auch da muss man sagen,
naja, wer ist denn die Zielgruppe, die langfristig die Spiele spielt?
Das ist es, da hat er Recht.
Das ist nicht, lass mich raten,
Lost sagt jetzt sowas wie,
das ist nicht, nicht Timmy aus der Nachbarschaft oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist auch bei Battlefield.
Wer ist denn die Zielgruppe, die langfristig...
Irgendwie sowas, kommt da jetzt.
Ich, ich, ich, ich predikte es schon mal.
Es ist nicht Casual Bernd.
Okay, Bernd, Bernd, nicht Timmy aus der Nachbarschaft,
es ist Casual Bernd in dem Fall, alles klar.
...ein Shooter ausprobiert.
Oder es ist es auch nicht Casual TimTam, der sich denkt, oh, ich spiele jetzt ab und zu mal ein bisschen hier neben meinem Liga-Kurs ins Battlefield, weil ich dort auch was reißen kann. Das sind die Battlefield-Friends, das sind die Battlefield-Fans, die Hardcore-Battlefield-Spieler, wenn man es mal so nennen möchte, die halt die Teile davor gespielt haben, die teilweise jetzt auch noch auf Battlefield 4, Battlefield Bad Company, von mir aus sogar auch Hardline, holy shit, hängen geblieben sind.
Und diese Spiele teilweise, obwohl die vor acht Jahren rausgekommen sind, immer noch aktiv auf den Servern, die noch laufen, spielen.
Das stimmt.
Diese Zielgruppe musst du doch am Schluss tangieren. Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Und diese Zielgruppe ist aktuell meinem Effekt nach und dem auch, was ich so mitbekommen habe und auch lesen kann und hören kann da draußen.
Nee, finde ich, dass er übertreibt. Der hat schon recht.
Guckt mal, wer heute dem Spiel die Treue hält.
Das sind die Leute, die einfach...
So, die Hardcore-Battlefield-Fans, das sind die, die sie ausgenommen haben mit ihrer Nostalgie-Werbung.
Und da bin ich ihnen wirklich böse drum.
Und das ja auch kritisieren aktuell, was hier in 2042 geändert wurde, auch teilweise im Vergleich zu Battlefield 5.
Was ich persönlich auch nicht nachvollziehen kann, weil das Game ja eigentlich auf BF5 krass basiert.
Und ich hab's letztens schon mal genannt, Battlefield 5, einer der Battlefield-Teil war, zuletzt, der letzte,
den ja viele nicht so gefeiert haben, aber der trotzdem einige Sachen gut gemacht hat, die ich mir auch hier gewünscht habe.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich Battlefield 2042 jetzt sehe, hätte ich mir gewünscht, doch mehr Battlefield 5 zu spielen.
Weil, also, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es schlechter werden kann.
Und auch davon ausgegangen bin tatsächlich, dass die so drin sind, weil es komplett Sinn macht und halt auch wirklich was Gutes war.
Movement-Geschichten oder auch das Weapon-Handling.
Das war jetzt auch nicht perfekt, da gab's auch auf die gewisse Entfernung, gab's da auch Streuung und so.
Aber die waren nicht ansatzweise so stark wie hier.
Das kann ich nicht so sagen, ich hab das zu wenig gespielt.
Wenn du dahin geschossen hast, wo du hinschießen wolltest.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall ein Punkt, den müssen wir im Kopf behalten.
Auf, gib ihm, gib ihm, los, mach ihn platt.
Das werden sie sich wahrscheinlich auch zu...
Gib ihm, gib ihm.
Bam!
Schreckt!
Das ist auch ein Punkt, wo ich auch hinter stehe, ganz klar.
Fakt ist, mir macht das Game Spaß, auf jeden Fall.
Macht es echt Spaß.
Okay, das muss ich jetzt auch mal was zu sagen.
Ja, das Game hat seine Momente.
Aber mittlerweile muss ich sagen, der Aufrege zu Spaß, die Aufrege zu Spaß-Ratio ist bei mir mittlerweile zu verschoben.
Deswegen war das heute wahrscheinlich auch der letzte Tag.
Und die Leute mal Headshot ist, die Leute auch weglasern und so.
Und du musst dich auf gewisse Gegebenheiten einfach komplett einstellen und auch umstellen.
Wie du dich bewegst, wie du movest, wie du agierst.
Wie du deinen Playstyle halt an den Start bringst.
Okay, du musst Pfeifert sein, möchte er sagen.
Das kann ich. Das ist okay. Das kann ich schon machen.
Aber, für mich persönlich ist diese Umstellung oder diese Anpassung, in Anführungsstrichen, auch ein Stück weit begrenzt.
Gerade was zeitliche Aspekte angeht.
Soll heißen...
Ja, okay, ich glaube, ich habe es in der Aussage verstanden.
Ja, gäbe ich ihm, gäbe ich ihm, du grüßt da wirklich komplett recht.
Zeig mal, wie sieht denn die Metakritik aus?
Ist es noch ein schlechter geworden?
Steam?
Guck mal mal, Steam...
Äh, ah, Moment, Moment.
Die Applikatorische, wie sieht es mit New World aus?
Okay, immer noch schlecht.
Ist das so, ist das so Fail, Alter?
Easy.
Äh, okay.
Steam Battlefield 2042.
Okay, ist immer noch richtig, richtig gut, wie es aussieht.
26% sind positiv.
Hey, das ist 1% mehr als gestern.
Gestern waren es, glaube ich, 25%.
1% mehr positiv.
Bock.
Es geht aufwärts, Leute.
Okay.
Boomer.
Bett.
Müde.
Schon spät.
Wupp.
Bettge.
Übrigens, Leute, ich muss jetzt mal eine Sache loswerden.
Schön, dass die letzten Tage, auch wenn ich mich ein bisschen über das Spiel aufgeregt habe,
so viele Leute eingeschaltet haben.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, ich mache normalerweise, ehrlich gesagt,
eigentlich weniger Battlefield und Gaming.
Ich mache...
Eigentlich...
Fast mehr IT-Geschichten auf Twitch.
Aber trotzdem schön, dass ihr da gewesen seid.
Vielleicht ist ja...
Wie gesagt, vielleicht spiele ich auch noch mal ein paar mal Battlefield in nächster Zeit.
Äh, wenn es euch gefallen hat, könnt ihr trotzdem gerne followen.
Würde mich sehr freuen.
Könnt auch mal bei mir auf Twitter oder auf YouTube vorbeigucken.
Und vielleicht sehen wir uns ja da.
Und sind bestimmt auch viele von YouTube da, die jetzt über die Verlinkung in den Kommentaren das hergefunden haben.
Wir hatten übrigens gestern oder vorgestern hier den ersten...
Seit einer Weile...
Meile...
Einen Stein wieder.
Wir haben es nämlich geschafft.
19.000...
Äh...
Follower auf Twitch.
Richtig massive Pock.
Also...
Wir sehen uns.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.